Maro is catching strays, ladies and
gentlemen. Maro is catching strays in
this message.
>> I I reached out to Auggie yesterday
because I retweeted the video like
>> this is why even [__] reference it.
Why even address it then? You should be
policing the community that you're a
part of.
>> Um, Willie Mack. Okay, I'm pretty sure
Willy Mack called me a pedto.
>> You called yourself that?
>> Acting as if like that Epanada didn't
just like dox someone.
>> Hey, how are you? Oh my god, dude. Holy
[__] Yeah, that's how you're supposed
to act. If you don't want to spread a
dox, then you should, you know, be like,
"Oh, this is weird." And then [__]
stop watching it. Don't drag attention
to it. What do you want him to do?
>> Yeah. And he got doxed. I love that.
>> Yeah, but you don't really have to say
that, Auggie.
>> Where? Why would Queen be okay with
Willie being doxed? Where have you Okay,
this is [__] This is [__] I
mean, I don't really know what I
expected.
Queman's [__] evil, man. We got to do
something about this Queman guy. Okay,
this is a this is a star tweet. Okay,
this is a star tweet. Is it true that
Auggie left because of Salvo harassing
him? If so, does he have any thoughts
about Quean and Salvo collaborating
recently? Like, she's so [__]
ratchet, dude.
She her stardust and [__] food shops
are like the same the same genre of
people in terms of like
Queenman [__] mind raped them and
they don't know how to handle it. So
their their first like their first
instinct is to try to get their little
jabs in whenever they can, get their
little punches in whenever they can.
Does he have thoughts about Quean? Does
he have thoughts about Quean?
Queenman's [__] evil, man. We got to
do something about this queen guy. Shut
the [__] up. He called you an oinker
piggy [__] You wretched lying scum
[__] piece of [__] Shut the [__] up. I
wonder what Auggie thinks about this. I
wonder what your dead fodder would think
about you. I was limited. I was limited
by the tweet. I did have something in
there about craving uncircumcised South
African [__] I did have that in there.
I had to cut it. I had to cut it. Okay.
I had to cut it. Uh the tweet did not
let me type it all. Okay. The tweet did
not let me type it all, so I had to cut
some of it out. I had to cut the
uncircumcised South African cockpit out.
And then she responds.
She responds. She's like [__]
Lau, this guy is so pathetic. Won't call
in, by the way. Look at him trying
everything under his son to get my
attention. You literally replied to the
tweet. You literally replied to the
tweet and you're you're saying, "This
guy thinks he can get my attention." You
replied. You replied, "Fuck. Wretched
lying scum [__] piece of [__] Shut the
[__] up. I wonder what your dead father
feels about you." Someone check on Mal.
He seems lonely. What is that? How How
do you correlate this? I called you
oinker. I called you an oinker piggy.
And your first instinct is, "Oh, he must
be lonely."
Is this like the pet names that Becket
would use to you? Like, please, please.
Piggy, I'm lonely.
Or Becket has like a British accent,
right? I got to hold on.
Hello. Hello. Hello, little little
piggy. I'm lonely. Little piggy, I'm
lonely. Is this like the things that
Becket would say to you? You know,
bedtime talk or whatever? Like how do
you how do you correlate this with with
lonely? What do you get there? This girl
has like no semblance of like
of of of how basic humans feel. She's
like laring as as someone who has like
feelings about anything. It's very
interesting. There was one person who
who kept replying to these. I'm not
logged in, so I'll have to copy paste
these.
This Mike the Mutant guy.
This Mike the mutant guy.
Queen's [__] So, it's basically just
this tweet. They reply, "You're a failed
streamer and terminally online [__]
Honestly, you're incredibly irrelevant.
So much so when you die, no one will
remember you. When you're done sucking
off that [__] Brit bonger, remember
to wipe the [__] off your face. You got
[__] in your blood, which I do, by the
way. Everybody does. Okay, you get your
[__] chromosomes and [__] from your
mom and your dad. So, this this is just
like a lack of knowledge of [__] like
biology, okay? This is some wretched
stuff. And then I ask him, "What does
Brit Bonger mean?" And he just doesn't
reply. He just doesn't reply. I don't
know what that word means.
I don't know what that word means. Why
would I know what that word means? What
is britbonger?
This is like French maybe. I don't know.
German maybe. I think Mike does derive
from Germanic
Germanic language or something. I guess.
But if you go to Stardust account,
she is actually I don't know if it'll
show it.
Let me see.
So she tweets it.
Oh, I will not show the replies. She
retweets her own post.
So in her post, this guy's so pathetic.
Look at him trying everything under the
sun to get my attention instead of not
giving me the attention. Not giving me
the content. She makes the post. One, I
already won. I won the moment you fall
for the [__] You fall for it. Okay. I
won the I win the minute you fall for
it. All right. I win the minute you do
that. And then you [__] retweet it.
And then you [__] retweet it.
And know there's that that mic guy,
right? I brought him up for a reason. I
might have to find the tweet. I might
have to find the tweet.
Um,
hold on.
it. Okay. Well, I mean, we we can
literally just use this one. People
People keep saying this, and I know me
addressing this is probably going to
make it happen more because, you know,
I'm showing people that it gets under my
skin. People keep saying like, "Oh,
you're just copying the Queen. You're
just copying the Queen. You're just
copying Queen. You're sucking all
whatever." Dude, I've watched zero Queen
coverage on [__] Stardust. I find it
incredibly boring. I don't like
Stardust. The same way I haven't watched
any of his coverage really on Aerodite,
okay? Okay, I just think Aerodite is
really boring and even when someone is
like making the content a little more
interesting, I just can't find
entertainment in it. Right. All of my
criticisms are stardust. I don't even
know if Queen has made the same
criticisms. But even if he has, my
criticisms are of behavior she displayed
recently in a stream that she did less
than a week ago.
So I don't understand, right? When
people like Leia something who's like a
wretched lying scum [__] [__] as well,
a bad faith [__] loser apparently.
Okay, I would not have said this more
than a week ago before I I heard her
parro these opinions. When I lay out my
criticisms and I say I am critiquing you
for this recent thing that Queman hasn't
even [__] looked at, what am I
supposed to feel? What am I supposed to
feel? Okay. Well, you're you're just
copying Queman. Obviously [__] not.
Obviously [__] not. Am I copying
Quean because I don't like Willie Mack
and Queman also doesn't like Willie
Mack? Am I copying Queeman because
Queean doesn't like Stardust and I also
don't like Stardust? Like, is that the
level of [__] that we're at? It's the
same [__] Like, people people are
calling me snaky for [__] criticizing
Becket. It's like, bro, you don't even
know the terms that you're [__]
using. How have I snaked Becket? I still
like Becket. I'm still friends with him.
I don't know if he's friends with me. I
don't know how he feels about me. He
might [__] want me dead. I don't
know. Who gives a [__] Who gives a
[__]
Sure,
buddy. We all know you're a failed queen
and orbiter. What does that even mean?
What does that even mean?
What does that even mean? What does a
failed queen orbiter even look like?
Jesus. Okay, I think this guy tweeted
more. I'd have to check. Hold on. This
is the only one I saved because I he
didn't reply to me. I thought that was
funny.
Let me see.
Oh, so this guy just doesn't like
commentary YouTube. Is that what this
is?
Are you the guy who would take Blocks
and Auggies loads? It seems like he just
doesn't like commentary YouTube.
Interesting.
Oh, he's a Destiny fan.
Okay, well that makes sense.
Okay, this guy's a DJer. Awesome. He's a
DGER and a Stardust fan. Okay, W.
And he doesn't like Caseyron.
Auntie's anti-aga.
MAGA be like, "We're pro pedophilia now.
Deal with it, libtard." Dude, this guy
rules.
Okay. Well, w I guess I did get owned in
this. I will admit. I will admit I did
get owned here. Okay, I did get owned
here. Is there any other stardust [__]
I mean, people were replying saying that
I said something like [__] crazy.
Which did I did I really say something
like that insane? I don't know, I guess.
Um,
could I just look at this tweet and see
the replies?
Kitty needs some catnip and head
scratches. Chill TF out, [__]
Okay, don't clip that. I I said I don't
clip that. He has sex with little
babies, I think. I don't even know who
this is in reference to. I don't even
know who this is in reference to to
Queman to to Queman
to this Queen or is this in reference to
me? I don't know. Like I I this is all
just so bizarre. These people are so so
bizarre.
What are the tweets looking like to
this?
Oh man, Queman's [__] cockle sleeve
is mad at you again. Like what the [__]
What opinions have I like parited from
Queenman? I'm so This is just like such
a non-engagement [__] talking point.
Like this is literally just like one of
the things that pisses me off. Okay,
this is the thing that pisses me off the
most. Okay, and I'll I'll be upfront
about this. Non-engagement. This is like
not engag. Do you have an issue with
anything I said? Okay, you're just going
to like not engage and and do this like
[__] thing. It's like no, she is
like a lying [__] [__] Like yeah,
but whatever. Okay, what else is there
to What else do I need to cover?
Queen's cockleaf. [__] you. [__] you.
[__] you.
You're saying I'm this guy's [__]
sleeve? That's who you're saying I'm the
[__] sleeve of? You're saying I'm this
guy's [__] You're saying I have sex with
this guy? That's what you're saying?
You're saying I put this guy's wiener in
my mouth? That's what you're saying? No.
No. Dispelling the rumors now. No. No, I
would not have sex with Queman. I would
not have sex with Quean. Dickers.
Okay, he's on the table. Quean. No. All
right. No,
we can we can have a conversation about
Dickers. We can have a conversation
about what Dickers would have to do to
himself uh to, you know, to have me be
willing to have sex with him on camera.
But Queenman, no. No, no, no, no, no,
no,
no, no, no,
no, no, no. All right. No, no, no.
Okay. Uh,
44 viewers. Wow, you guys really have
nothing else to do, huh? I mean, there's
this Jessica Pizzle tweet. She said
something [__]
Um,
it's just like, bro,
w tweet, w tweet. Quan does it bad
because he hates Willie and more likely
to do it and not care. Okay, again,
like, okay, I I
feel stupid even trying to [__] talk
about this.
Also, moral, look in DMs. What are you
sending me? You haven't sent me
anything.
You did not DM me anything.
What am I supposed to be looking at?
Who even are you? Rayanne, who are you?
My DMs are empty. I don't
Sorry.
Sorry. Okay. Quan does it bad because he
hates Willie and more likely to do it
and not care. Uh Quimman didn't dox
anyone. Queman did not amplify the
docs.qman replied or looked at Destiny's
tweet. Quan didn't look at the tweet
about Willie.
Quean didn't look at anything other than
the [__] Destiny tweet.
This is like pure [__] [__]
like [__]
Destiny does it bad but forgivable. No,
it's not forgivable. This is [__]
This is [__] As Destiny doesn't
hate Willie and most likely felt bad and
cared. He does not feel bad.
He absolutely does not feel bad. And I
believe there's even a clip. Hold Let me
find this.
Who sent this [__] Yeah, Lumpy Willie
the goat.
>> Um, I'm sorry, Willie. I don't know if
this [__] Willie or not. Oh, I guess
he maybe he sounds like it doesn't
[__] But now I don't care. Now I just
[__] it. If you're ducks, you're ducks.
I'm just going to be I'm not going to
let that slow me down. Outing these
[__] weirdos himself, cuz you can't.
>> Does this Does this seem like he feels
bad and he cared? No, obviously not.
He didn't feel bad and he cared. He has
a vendetta against uh you know [__]
bad empanada which could be justified. I
don't know. And I don't really care. I
don't really care to look into what Bad
Panata has done to Destiny, right? Uh
but Destiny has also doxed people
maliciously. So Destiny has also doxed
people maliciously. Destiny has also
targeted people maliciously uh and
spread their docs. Implicitly spread
their docs. Even look at Annavore. Look
at Annavore when he was like, "Go to her
Kiwi Farms page when her docs was
there." Destiny is not an idiot. Destiny
is not stupid. Okay, he knows what he
was doing with Anavore. Uh he's The only
difference is like now he's not doing,
you know, it implicitly, right? In the
month of July alone, right? In the month
of July alone, uh he he attempted to dox
Jtock 10 [__] times. 10 [__]
times. I am not joking. I am not joking.
This is literally in my script for the
Willie Mac video. I am quoting this from
my script where I'm going to site
everything visually and whatever. He
tried to dogs Jtock 10 times in [__]
July.
That is once every 3 days.
Okay. So, acting like this guy feels bad
about doxing at all is [__] [__]
I don't know how that's a confusing
concept. Yeah, because you're [__]
delusional. You're like actually [__]
brain rotted. Would I exhibit that
behavior publicly? No. But it's not
confusing unless you are blind or dumb.
No. Spreading a dox does and I I tweeted
this, right? I I did like a little quote
tweet to this. I won't pull it up
because I'll just reiterate the same
thing here.
If you if you amplify a doc, right? I'm
not saying Destiny doxed Willie. I'm not
saying even JTO doxed Willie. None of
these people doxed Willie, right? Um, I
think it's more described as like the
the initial Kiwi Farms post, probably
Doc Willie or even Bad Empanata who made
it more widespread, right?
Shoo [__]
But
amplifying a doc, making a docs easier
to to find, to look at, to explore, to
identify, whatever you want to call it,
is irreparably damaging. That
information is never going to be hidden
again.
Willy's wife's name is never going to be
hidden again.
Willy's name is never going to be hidden
again. This information about them is
irreparably out there. Nothing can be
done to remove it. Willie has included
his wife's name uncensored in his
[__] YouTube video. Nothing can be
done now. So, no, it doesn't matter that
Destiny was defending Willie, which he
wasn't. He was just criticizing bad
empanada. That is not a defense. That is
not saying like, "No, you shouldn't have
doxed Willie." It's literally just
saying like, "Any and all [__] any
and all things are are okay against bad
empanada." Now, that's not a defense,
[__] You're a [__] idiot. Whoever
says it's a defense. I know Willie does.
Whoever else says that is [__]
delusional, right?
But no, it's not a defense. It's a It's
an attack on bad empanada,
right? It is basically you saying that
bad empanada is now, you know, available
to be doxed or targeted or whatever,
right?
[__] ridiculous. Absolutely like
mindmelting [__] here.
So, no,
nobody was being like this is not
forgivable. Spreading a doc, amplifying
a doc is bad, even if you care about it
essentially. I'm I'm I'm [__] winding
on too long about those [__]
[__] dude.
And then like his his offline DG shot.
Is that what this is called? I think
you read bottom up, right? I don't
understand why some some chats read read
bottom up. It's so [__] Haha. Did
you guys see Destiny getting doxed? Man,
that's wild. You know those? Nobody
doxed him. Just dock someone's phone
number. Just dock someone's address,
Pepe. Just dock someone's social
security. Pepe. He's not afraid of
getting doxed by my community. He's just
saying that because he didn't want him
uh to get caught lying about his job.
the guys who were both crying like
babies when KF KF doxed them and now ran
away to the internet. Like, yeah. No,
bro. Uh, nice name, bro. He gave enough
info away for him and Zoe, his Discord
kit, to be fully doxed. Like, this guy
does not give a [__] about doxing
like this. This what this is, right? Cuz
I do want to eventually watch some of
the um Is my mouse dying? I do. I got to
plug this [__] in, bro. Do I got to plug
this [__] in? It is dying. Uhoh. Plug it
on. I got a wireless mouse, folks. I am
uh I'm I'm swimming in money. I'm not
I'm lying.
But I appreciate the donuts. Listen, I'm
going to watch Tommy C in food shops cuz
I was watching Queen and he's like, I'm
not going to watch other people's
coverage. I'll fill that void. Okay?
I'll fill that void. I will 1,000%
1 million% uh watch what Food Shops has
to say.
I will fill the market replacement for
food shops content.
No, I mean this is just [__] What
what this on the Tommy C note, right? On
the Tommy C note, obviously what this is
is like there there is there are two
sides of commentary, right? Not really.
There's there's [__] 10 or something.
I don't know. But one of the sides of
commentary are are are the people who
really want to defend like Tommy C. And
those people who defend Tommy C are
naturally, you know, opposed to people
like Chudlo Logic or opposed to people
like Queenman or all of those people,
right?
And it it's it's almost like these
people don't think for the fuckingelves.
They have no opinions. They have no
critical thinking skills. They have no
original thought. Uh nothing. Zero
nothing. Zilch. Okay. This Jessica
Pizzle person just wants to suck up to
Tommy C because Tommy C called her tits
fat one time.
Where's the clip? Do we have that clip,
chat? Do we have that clip, chat?
Where is it?
Where's the clip? Where is it? Where is
it, man?
Where is it, man?
[__] Where is it? It's the It's the
drunk clip. Where is it?
Did he delete it?
No.
No,
Tommy.
Oh, don't tell me he deleted it.
[__] Okay. Well, if anyone has the
drunk clip, send it to me. I'll pull it
up. Cuz Jessica Pizzle was on stream and
Tommy C was drunk and he was uh
complimenting her her her fat old hag
tits.
>> Heartbreaking. The most busted
commentary he had hammer on and just
made a great point.
>> Are you [__] Are you [__] stupid
as [__] dude? Are you [__] What
about this was a good point? What about
this was a good point, Jimberly? You
[__] [__] dumb [__] Huh?
I'm gonna get I'm gonna [__] I'm
gonna get drunk. I'm gonna get
belligerent. I'm gonna do something
crazy. I'm gonna start drinking I'm
gonna start drinking copious amounts of
alcohol. I'm going to turn on my live
stream and I'm going to I'm going to
start doing crazy [__] I'm going to
start doing crazy [__] and nobody's
going to be able to stop me. Nobody's
going to be able to stop me.
drunk driving stream. True. No, but it's
just like it it's like this this
mindless drone glazing. How much do you
want to bet that that Tommy C is going
to go on stream and uh and and parrot
something similar to this? How much do
you guys want to bet?
Like this is just [__] [__] I
actually want to see if uh if YouTube
drama is talking about this.
I I assume they are. I assume they are.
Quinton Reviews was contacted by Mr.
Beast. Wurely
they're talking about it.
Oh, they're not. Okay. Whatever.
Whatever. Sure. Sure, man. Whatever. I
don't even care. I don't even care.
All right. There's some other Twitter
[__] I want to look at before I watch uh
the epic coverage. The epic epic
coverage.
There's the Chudlo Logic VOD.
People always comment when there's
something. Augie calls in at 1 minute
26.
Or do you mean 1 hour 26?
Yeah,
actually there were like there were he
he sent Willie like a DM about Yeah. a
DM and he was like, "Stop arguing with
moral
>> because I just want to clear the record
on this once and for all before we get
to the video. I won't reveal anything
else about
>> Let me turn off the [__] slot music,
okay? We're not Listen, no more kids
gloves, okay? We're adults here. We
don't need the Animal Crossing music
background. All right.
>> The conversation,
it will literally just be my message and
I will leave the audience to determine
whether they think this constitutes a
snaky message or not. Okay.
So, here's the message that I sent. It
was on the 18th of February. Okay. And
it was off the back of people being
critical of that first video that he did
about Destiny.
This this is all the context you need.
There's nothing before this that you
need to see. Okay.
Um the next line that you're not seeing
is Willy's response and he's just not
interested in talking. And you know
beyond that I don't really want to talk
about it further. But that that's you
know if Willie Matt can test this he can
obviously release more of the messages
if he so wishes. Okay. But these are the
messages that apparently led Willie Mack
to believe along with my coverage on
stream of his video that I'm snaky.
So I messaged him and I said, "Hey man,
hope you're well, dude. Just wanted to
give you some friendly advice to stop
fighting with utter [__] like Maro."
>> Okay, people sent me this clip like like
five different people sent me this clip,
by the way, thinking that I was going to
be like outraged at this. They're like,
"Dude, Chud [__] hates you." Or
something. No, he's just right. He's
just [__] right. How many subscri How
many views do I get? How many viewers do
I get? I have I have [__] 40 viewers
right now. I have 40 viewers right now.
I have 40 viewers right now. Yeah, I'm a
complete and total [__] You should
not be responding to me. If you have
like any any [__] you know,
self-respect, you should not be
responding to me. Right. This Willie
Mac. Okay. Does this speak to me at all?
Yeah. Okay. I have [__] I have I have
time to spend arguing with Willie Mack
on Twitter. Okay. But Willie spent like
an entire day arguing with me. Even when
I got [__] wrong, when I was literally
wrong in the argument and he proved me
wrong. I kept arguing with him. All
right. I'll literally admit this. I kept
arguing with him and he kept [__]
responding.
So like, yeah. No, this is just put out
your video unless you get something
egregiously wrong, which to be fair, I
think he did. Um, don't respond to it.
Make a statement. Don't [__] argue
with [__] on Twitter. That is like
the most [__] thing you can ever
[__] do as a creator. It just makes
you look like a [__] idiot. You're
like falling for Twitter [__] Uh,
like literal nobodies. I get no views.
Nobody knows who I am. I I I am a
complete and utter [__] nobody. Okay?
You should absolutely not You should
absolutely not uh be arguing with me on
Twitter. That is like a total [__]
waste of time, right? Even back to
Stardust. Why the [__] is Stardust
arguing with me on Twitter? I obviously
said something unhinged and then she's
like, I'm not going to give you
attention and then gives me [__]
attention. It's like, bro, if you really
cared about not like, don't don't
[__] reply to this [__] It's just
going to egg me on. I'll be open about
it. Okay, I'll be open about it. All
right, I'll be open about it.
Okay,
this is egging me on. I'm not going to
stop now. I'm not going to stop now. You
think I'm going to stop now? No,
obviously not. I'm going to keep going.
[__] this stardust [__] I know. Now I
know what [__] triggers her. She
doesn't like being called an oinker.
Okay, this brown Punjabi [__] doesn't
like being called an oinker. What's that
one? Um, hold on.
I've got one last job before we wrap
things up.
Amita needs to go.
>> Stardust needs to go. I got one last job
before we one last job. Stardust, she
needs to go. She needs to go.
Me walking into Stardust streaming setup
while she's talking to her chat. you.
He sent you to kill me.
I knew he'd come to this, but you.
>> Who else pulls the trigger around here?
>> Good point.
>> Sabal hides behind his blind faith in
tradition. And
>> Quimman hides behind his bad faith and
lies.
>> You just you follow along like one of
his subjects.
I actually believed you when you said
all you wanted to do was honor your
mother's dying wish.
>> I actually believed you when you said
you wanted to debate about Willie Mag's
destiny videos.
>> Go on, son of Mohan, savior of Kirat.
Follow your orders. Pull the trigger.
I'm sure it's the will of Kira.
Wow.
Wow. Cinematic. Cinematic, dude.
>> Maro is catching strays, ladies and
gentlemen. Maro is catching strays in
this message. Okay. There's nothing I
can do about that. It is what it is.
Okay. It is what it is.
>> Because what he was doing is he was
having these like ongoing Twitter
arguments.
>> Is is Chud Hold My chat's covering it.
Is Chud in this stream sponsored by
Roblox.
That's epic. Okay, that's cool. W
>> total [__] nobodyies.
>> And I just thought, well, that's stupid.
You know, word to the wise, don't
[__] do that, right? Okay.
If if I'm snaking anyone, it's Maro. But
who [__] cares about Maro anyway?
>> True. First of all, I don't see this as
Okay. I don't know what people think the
term [__] snaking means. First of
all, like, okay, to clarif No, I I don't
[__] take this as snake. Obviously
not. That's [__]
I think you'd be a [__] [__] to
take this like, stop arguing with this
guy on Twitter. Like, no. Obviously not.
I don't give a [__] I don't view this
as snaky. What do people think [__]
snaking means? What do people think
[__] snaking means? People have been
saying that I'm like I've I've I've seen
people say, "Okay, I've seen people say,
"Oh, bro, you're you're like you you
snaked Becket. You snaked Becket." Am I
not allowed to be critical of someone
that I like that I view as like a a
friendesque figure, you know, online
friends. Obviously, it's different than
like a, you know, close personal in real
life friend or whatever, right? It's
like, dude, what the [__] do you think
snaking means? I don't know Chud. I've
talked to him maybe twice,
maybe twice.
I know. I've definitely spoken to him
once. I think the only thing I've sent
Chud is like I saw him play Silent Hill
and I was like, "Oh, Silent Hill 2 is
one of my favorite games of all time.
I'll send him another horror game that I
liked." I was like, "Hey, you might like
this." I think that's literally the only
DM I've ever sent Chud. I could be
wrong, but like, no, I'm not friends
with this guy. I don't talk to this guy.
I've talked to him like like I can count
on one hand how many times I've spoken
to Chudlo Logic. Obviously, I'm not
going to view this as [__] snaking.
Okay.
What the [__] do people think snaking
means? Like
being mean is snaking. Yeah. It's like,
dude, these terminology in the [__]
commentary space, whatever space this is
that I inhabit, has like lost all
[__] meaning. Nobody knows what words
mean anymore.
I view snaking as like a betrayal. Okay,
a betrayal. How could I possibly have
[__] snaked Beckett? I I I accepted
his wishes. I accepted his wishes when
he told me that he didn't want to be
moral [__] too. And he didn't want me,
you know, bringing him with [__] and
saying that like demanding he care about
it. I was like, "Hey, all right. I won't
do that again. I didn't do it for Lio.
He came to me. He came to me to talk."
Okay. So, if he's annoyed by that,
that's on [__] him. All right. I like
Becket, but that's on [__] him. He's
like [__] He's a complete and utter
[__] If he's mad at that, he's
[__] He's not [__] broadly. I
like Becket. I like Becket. Okay. He did
do a stream uh critical of uh Willie
today, and I appreciated that. I thought
that was very cool. Okay, Becket is
turning Becket is turning a new leaf,
and it's good to see. It's good to see.
Durio's audience is saying, "Huh? Why
would Nick snake Willie by covering the
video?" Like, dude, they're so [__]
stupid.
And then Chud's going to go on and say
like, "Oh, Willie probably thought this
was a snaky message." It's like, how
could this be interpreted as snaky,
right? Outside of like, you know,
obviously he's not [__] snaking me. I
don't know the guy. I don't think he
could snake me. If Chud went like super
hard, like if Chud went if Chud went
nuclear on Mau, even then I wouldn't
think it's snaky. I don't give a [__]
I'm not friends with this guy. I don't
know this guy.
But just the me the message in and of
itself to Willie. How could this be
viewed as snaky? Like, yeah, it is it is
generally good advice to not argue with
people on Twitter. It's generally good
advice to to not [__] debate people
on [__] [__] that you're going to
look [__] for, you know, for arguing
for, right?
It's just so like
I
it's so [__] [__] that like
snaking.
It's like a come on. Come on, man.
Obviously, this is not [__] snaking
in any sense of the term to anybody,
right?
In any sense of the term to [__]
anybody. Nobody knows what [__]
snaking means. I don't believe I've
snaked anyone. If you could even if you
could even say that I've snaked someone,
I think the only person that you could
you could definitively say I snaked
would probably be Himleton. Like, I
could understand why people would think
that I snaked Himleton. Okay, I have my
reasons for distancing myself, right? I
think Himleton's improved a lot. I would
be fine with being friends with him. I'd
be fine with co-hosting or having him on
as a co-host at this point. I don't
care. I think he's improved. I don't
think he's going to do some like insane
optically like horrific [__] again. I
hope. Okay. But yeah, I'd be fine with
being friends with him again. I don't
care. But yeah, at the time I just
wanted to distance myself because he was
doing insane [__] Uh I viewed insane
[__] like behind the scenes he was just
lying to me. I felt like he was lying.
And then he obviously got into that
[__] call with ZV and did the whole
like Joker monologue. It's like, yeah,
obviously I'm not going to want to be
involved in that. I'm I'm I'm backing
away. I am backing out of that. I am
backing away. Backing out of that. I
don't want to be involved in that. Okay.
I don't want to be involved there.
But yeah, like I I don't know. I don't
know even what people think [__]
snaking is. It's so [__] All right,
that was a stupid [__] deer. Let's
Let's see the Auggie Colin, I guess.
Sure.
>> Think let's see. Let's see about this.
Yo
>> yo, Orie, how's it going?
>> What's going on, man? Long time no talk.
>> Um, yeah, I think the last time that we
spoke was the uh the the New Year
stream, in fact.
>> Actually, yeah, that's kind of crazy.
Well, maybe during the Destiny drama, we
talked a bit during that, but yeah,
>> maybe. I mean, that that stream, I don't
know if you're aware, has been uh very
uh very famous, much discussed. Well,
dude, I feel like I've uh surpassed the
amount of trouble that I was in from
that stream with my own comeback stream
I did two weeks ago. I think everything
I said on that stream got me into some
sort of trouble in like
>> actually briefly
>> briefly
briefly really quick because if I don't
cover this I'm going to [__] forget.
So, I I I made this post on Twitter,
right? I need to talk about this now or
I'm actually gonna forget because I'm
moving away from the Twitter [__] We're
not going to do [__] Twitter react.
Okay. Nicholas Dioro after promising to
watch the new Willy Mack video on stream
takes his uh uh Nicholas Dorio after
promising to watch the new Willy video
on stream takes us back and begins
blocking people like Quan who are
accused of hosting doxing communities in
set video. These are false claims and
this seems to be implicit support for
misinformation, which I agree with.
Okay, so we have this screenshot.
You could just say it's Willie. So 3,000
retards don't think this is about me.
Uh, will you watch the video? Basically,
uh, maybe when I get around to watching
it tomorrow. He'll watch the video
tomorrow. He'll watch the video
tomorrow. And then here it is.
Still haven't watched it. And I probably
won't jump into the gay commentary civil
war on the grounds that everyone is
frothing at the mouth begging me to. I
think Auggie and Will Willie can settle
their own [__] So no, he's not going to
watch it on stream. He's a [__]
coward.
Nicholas is a [__] coward. Spineless
[__] Nobody, and I do mean nobody,
nobody should be respecting this [__]
guy.
>> Nobody should be Nobody should be
respecting this guy.
And the [__] screen recording I got
isov. God damn it.
I have to [__] convert it so I can
play this on [__] stream. God damn
it. Okay, hold on.
>> Guys, I have
>> All right.
And I also include this video which I'll
just play the clip of now.
>> Guys, I have
key update.
Nicholas Dioro has now blocked me on
Twitter. Nicholas Dioro has now
officially blocked me on Twitter for
being slandered by William. It's not
like the old days anymore where
>> so yeah the people that in this video
right in this video that he's refusing
to watch refusing in air quotes I'm sure
he's actually watched it but these
people that he's you know
refusing to watch the video the people
that are included Quean and Jtock are
being accused of hosting docsing
communities and accused of being the
reason uh that J not Jtock that Willie
Mack was ultimately doxed which is just
blatantly untrue factually untrue
literally factually untrue provably
untrue. He does not provide any
evidence. The evidence he does provide
uh proves him wrong in fact, right? So
he says, "I will watch it tomorrow."
Then you know changes his mind and then
blocks Queman
and then blocks Queman. This in my eyes
is absolutely nothing other than
implicit support for the misinformation
that Willie is spreading. Quan didn't
tweet at Nick as far as I know. Quean
didn't DM Nick as far as I know. Nick
went out of his way to block Queman out
of nowhere.
So yeah, this this is absolutely uh
implicit support for misinformation.
Undoubtedly so. Undoubtedly so. In my
mind. Okay, maybe I'll change my mind
later. I don't know. But yeah, as of
now, I 10,000% think that uh Nick is a
is a coward.
Nick is a coward. Nobody with any amount
of like principles or or anything should
be uh supporting this guy. Nobody who,
you know, disagrees with doxing should
be supporting Nick if he won't take a
stand against misinformation around
doxing. If he won't, you know, self
police and stuff like that. Uh this is
the same Nick who self-p policed with
technicals. This is the same Nick that
would constantly go on to RFC uh and
constantly go on to like Doc on the
radio and stuff. I believe Doc on the
radio and like argue with people. Okay.
Uh he's just like his balls have shrank.
He's like on estrogen. His ball is a
[__] shrink. His [__] is like
whittleled and tiny. Uh, this is
horrific stuff. This is horrific stuff.
Literally, nobody should respect this
guy. He is a [__] fraud. Okay, but
here's the call-in with uh Chad and
Auggie.
>> Every community that I covered that
stream. It's actually insane. And just
when I thought I was out of the weeds,
this [__] Willie video just drops out
of [__] nowhere. Like genuinely like
So,
slow down. Wait. We got some other
business to attend to, mate.
I made some comments about you, didn't
I?
>> Oh, yeah. Let's just get that out of the
way. Dude, I don't give a [__] You
[__] [__] You [__] talked my stream.
We [__] We [__] talked you back. Like,
who cares? You know what I mean? Like, I
did not take that super personally. I
mean, in the moment, like when you were
like [__] on my show or something, I
probably was like, "Ah, [__] this guy."
Or something like that, right? But like,
yeah, like long term, like I don't give
a [__]
>> Yeah, dude. Well, you know, obviously,
you know, I don't really like the tricks
or treat stuff, but I I heard it was a
very good stream, very popular, and
hopefully you did take it in the
banteresque where it was intended. It
wasn't meant to be like a super serious
like [__] insult on you personally.
So,
>> well, dude, me and Connor love doing
these like gimmick streams where it's
all crazy. We've done like game shows.
We've set up like Among Us tournaments
in the past with other YouTubers. We
were doing the poker streams before. We
love these gimmicky type shows and just
setting them up, especially Connor. And
I like performing in them. So,
>> is Connor gay? Is Connor a homosexual?
Yes or no?
>> Whoa.
>> No. No. He's He's lives with a a woman.
So,
>> he's not gay.
>> Interesting. Okay.
>> Um, so yeah, I mean, dude, I mean, good
question, though.
>> You You say your piece. What What have
you got to say for yourself? Like,
what's going on, mate?
>> Yeah, I mean, there's a lot and
obviously I'm going to be, you know,
responding to this on my own platform. I
kind of have to. Um, but I mean, Willie
is very obviously hurt. I mean, he's
been uh I think Queean and Jtock, but
probably particularly Queman, although
he does really hate Jtock and he doesn't
like you either, by the way. And I'm
fine talking about that because clearly
he has no [__] issue
>> disclosing anything that we've ever
talked about. So, I mean,
>> okay, let's be narcissistic. Hit me. Hit
me. What's the problem with with it with
Chloic? What's going on?
>> Uh I think he just doesn't I think
there's a big paranoia
uh of like an anti community. You know
what I mean? I think there's a big
paranoia with an anti community and I
think Queenman and Jtock are sort of uh
looked at as these like figures that are
uh you know they can't be trusted. They
might do.
>> Also, one thing that's annoying, right,
one thing that's annoying is is all of
these anti-communities
are all grouped together, right? Every
single anti community is grouped
together and and they're treated as like
one [__] conglomerate, uh, you know,
mashed together [__] ball of people
when they're not, right? The Destiny
anti community is not just [__] Quean
and Jtock, okay? Destiny has debated
Nick Fuentes and then burned Nick
Fuentes. Uh the [__] Mr. Girl [__]
all these other shits. Destiny has
argued for [__] ethical CP. There are
multitudes, multitudes of ways people
could have naturally found Destiny,
naturally found his content, and then
naturally have been repulsed by it.
Okay? Acting as if it's just like this
brand new thing that's only occurring in
[__] Jtock and and and Quean and uh
and and whatever is is is [__] brain
dead.
Uh, Tyrone, I have a clip of it. I'll
pull it up in a second.
Wait, you aren't in the weekly anti-fan
meetings? Not yet. Not yet. I've
submitted my appeal or something.
But it it's just like, dude,
what the [__] is this? Like the
anti-communities, right? Obviously, I'm
not having an issue with anything that
Augie's saying, but the
anti-communities,
like Destiny has [__] brain broken
his audience so [__] hard to think
that this it's just it's just like one
group of people. Like, no. Destiny has
pissed off numerous communities,
numerous types of people, whether it be
right-wingers, whether it be uh
left-wingers, whether it be, you know,
acting like it's just like these two
like niche groups uh and then like
[__] Kiwi Farms. It's like it's just
[__] [__] It's so stupid.
>> They might form audiences that are just
going to be a [__] pain in our ass. I
think that's a lot of where it comes
down from. And I think in general, you
know, my biggest issue with Willie is
that he's not able to sort of uh
consider the criticism and see if
there's any value to it, you know, like
cuz I think when you get criticized,
obviously you should you shouldn't just
dismiss it immediately because what if
it's true, you know? You don't want to
just be hard stuck on one path. And so
when he's getting criticism for his
Destiny video, I think he immediately
like just throws it in the trash. He's
just like, "Ah, this is just stupid
[__] This is just spurouts. These are,
you know, Destiny snark communities that
are coming at me with all this
bullshit." But I I prefer an approach of
like, hey, let's, you know, sit down.
Let's think about let's think about what
they're saying for a second and see if
there's any weight to this and, you
know, we can have a discussion there.
But I think Willy's hardheaded. Wasn't
Wasn't your show often about a video
comes out, there's a disagreement with
how it's done, and then creators hop on
and and talk about it. I mean,
technicals is probably one of the best
examples of this.
>> Oh, yeah. Yeah, 100%. I mean, that
happened all the [__] time on uh, you
know, in the old days, but I think the
climate is much different nowadays. You
know, everyone's kind of in their own
community, in their own circle, on their
own channel, doing their own thing. It's
not like the old days anymore where you
know basically you had after hours you
know Thomas he was also in his show or
whatever. Right. But basically you had
these like live streams you know. Yeah
you had doc radio where it was just
constant like open door policy. Yeah.
Good guy. He's a good guy.
>> Yeah. Um but you know you have these
streams back in the day that were just
kind of open door programs where you
know that was the content. But I think a
big problem with that content is it is
kind of a pain in the ass for the
creators to engage all the time. And so
now everyone is sort of in their
fortress arc which I'm not saying is
even like a bad strategy or something.
It makes total sense to me but I think
everyone's a little bit too sensitive
when it comes to criticism on their
videos. And I feel like that's pretty
stupid. I don't know. Well, I think one
of the issues is that like maybe it
feels one side sometimes because strings
will criticize a video.
>> It does feel I guess a good way to to
put it is like there there's this error
like [__] Benji said earlier, people
think snaking is literally just being
mean. People have this weird view of
like social dynamics. I don't know if
it's because of co or like what happened
uh that like mind [__] people, mind
raped people into into having this like
bizarre view of like social dynamics.
Uh, but everyone seems to have like this
this really intense [__] ego about
their content, about their videos, about
their streams, about whatever. And if
you say anything bad about them, you're
like [__] you're you're you're you're
burning the bridge. The bridge is [__]
the bridge is [__] exploding. And
it's like, no, dude. Like, I cannot
You're allowed to not like something.
You're now you're allowed to not like
someone's streams. You're allowed to not
like someone's [__] videos. You're
you're allowed to not like uh whatever.
It's like this is such a [__]
[__] mindset. Again, not saying that
Auggie has this. It's just my perception
of the community as a whole. It's like
all of these people are like so
I don't Okay, I don't necessarily think
it's like insecurity,
right? I don't necessarily think it's
insecurity. I don't I don't think these
people are insecure, but I think they
have massive [__] egos, right? They
think their [__] is like really
fantastic. They think their stuff is
really really good. really really good.
Really, really good. I don't know if
it's I don't think it's insecurity. I
think it's egotistic.
I think all of these people assume that
their content is [__] phenomenal.
Absolutely no flaws, nothing. Nothing
wrong with it, whatever. And I think
that's the issue, right? Because the
moment Willie gets criticized, he's been
told by all his friends who probably
don't even watch his videos like, "Dude,
that was such a good Hassan video. You
[__] own that guy. All these videos
are really good." And then the moment
you start making videos that you know
are bad that are that have you know
maybe some wrong information in them
whatever you know whatever it's going to
sting a lot more right it's going to
sting a lot more
so and and Auggie goes on I don't want
to I mean you guys have probably already
seen this right I'm I'm live pretty late
after everyone else but Auggie basically
goes on to say like tell a story about
and and showcase how Willie Mac is is
like extremely [__] paranoid and it's
like Um,
yeah, this guy is just [__]
egotistic. This guy is 1,000% just
[__] egotistical. He's like a
paranoid loser who who is obsessed with
his own image and looking good. And the
moment he doesn't look good, he is uh he
gets like [__] freaked out. He
[__] spazzes out
>> cuz I think Willy Mack said to Que, "Why
don't you make a video?" And it almost
feels like, well, I don't get to
criticize you for your coverage. But you
can absolutely criticize a streamer for
their coverage if you want to. Um, yeah.
You know, I don't think you need to make
a video to make yourself subject to
criticism. just watch your stream and
go, they're wrong about this, they're
wrong about that. And um I don't know,
man. I mean, is that not what it's all
about? Like criticizing each other?
That's a lot of drama comes off of this.
>> But I think the problem from Willy's
perspective is honestly like he looks at
these communities and he's like,
engaging with this is just like it's not
worth it for me because they have the
tiny audience, I have the bigger
audience. It's not even it's not like an
equal I don't get nearly as much out of
engaging with this as they do with
engaging with me. So from his
perspective, he's probably looking at it
more like that where he's like it's
either out of like fear or it's out of,
you know, he just doesn't want to sort
of constantly be [__] bickering with
these smaller channels and stuff like
that. That's probably where he's coming
from. if I just had to guess. But yeah.
>> Um yeah, I mean that that's fine like
you know logic they want to pick with
smaller channels, but then it seems a
bit bizarre that you make a video
falsely claiming that the smaller
channel in my opinion claim that's the
[__] problem. It's like if you don't
engage with these people don't engage,
right? But clearly he wants to engage
with them but on his platform where he
can you know
>> create the narrative for himself, post
it to his channel, get the 100,000 views
because it's Hassan Slop and he can sort
of establish the narrative on these
smaller creators uh and not really have
to he can't he doesn't even have to
engage with them anymore because he's
already painted them as malicious
doxers. So therefore that's my out or
whatever, right? I can just, you know,
he wants to engage them, but in a way
where it's like a controlled environment
for him.
>> Yeah, sure. Um, okay. So,
>> I don't know.
>> What what's your sort of like a
response, I guess, or takes to Will Max
comments in regards to you?
>> Um, you were friends, I thought. No.
>> Yeah, we had a good conversation, or at
least I thought it was a good
conversation uh a month ago, and that's
actually the conversation he referenced
in his video. You know, he mentioned
something about how, first of all, I
think Willie, I don't know if he thinks
that I am like cool. I just don't care
that he got doxed. I was disgusted when
I found out that he got docked. I'm not
just saying that's just a virtue signal
right now. I legit was like, "Wow, that
really sucks." Like I didn't even know
what happened when it did happen. But
yeah, Nick told me like, "Yeah, Band Up
is running around with his docs and his
wife and stuff like that." And so I
pulled up his Twitter and I looked at it
and I was like, "Wow, this is actually
disgusting shit." But you know, when I
see somebody get docs, I'm not just
going to like, "Fuck, what am I supposed
to [__] tweet about it?" You know,
that's just going to encourage people to
look into it more.
>> My logic with doc stuff is always
ignore, ignore, ignore. Because the main
about it, you start drawing eyes to it.
And that's, you know, that's opposite
what you want to do.
>> True.
>> That is true. That is true. Do not
[__] respond to doces. Do not respond
to doces. You are just going to confirm
the doc is real, right? you are just
going to encourage it. You're a [__]
[__] Willie is such a [__]
[__] He literally went on Twitter,
started spuring, confirmed his docs, and
and likely, you know, plausibly put his
wife in [__] danger. They were
getting bomb threats. They were getting
[__] shooting threats or whatever the
[__] he said in his video. It's like,
bro, what are you what are you doing?
What are you [__] doing? What are you
doing, you [__] idiot? What are you
doing?
Like, yes, this is how you should
respond to doxing. Don't [__] talk
about it. Don't talk about it. Don't
amplify it. Don't encourage people to
look at it. Don't like if someone if one
of your friends gets doxed, don't say
like, "This is bad that they got doxed."
You're just going to feed people to that
doc.
Like this is so [__] this is so
[__]
>> Also, I mean, I understand Willie Max's
probably, you know, anxious about the
wedding stuff. I totally get that. I
have a problem with him talking about
necessarily because wedding's done now.
But there's also the mentality of like
you often don't want to draw attention
to your own doc's information. You want
to kind of like ignore as best as
possible, too.
Look, I can even excuse like I can even
look at it like, you know, Willy's
obviously, you know, probably a bit
hysterical about the docs. He's probably
a little bit emotional and stuff like
that. And so, it's fine for him to not
respond to it like, you know, completely
100% levelheaded. You know what I mean?
Like, obviously, that's completely fine,
but he's just
>> he's almost a 30-year-old man.
>> Uh, in my eyes, he should have the uh
the self-control to contain himself. I
don't agree with this at all. Um, I can
I can understand like, yeah, you're
emotional. you're you're probably not
going to act, you know, totally
levelheaded, but when you're when you're
pushing 30, like you should I feel like
you should have the self-control to to
maintain your feelings a little better,
right? And maybe I don't know. I'm not
30, so I don't know what it's like.
Okay. But I would feel like most
30-year-olds should have the ability to
to contain themselves, you know? So, it
is a little it is a little uh desperate.
It is a little desperate, I guess. I
don't know.
>> Is outright lying. I mean, he created
this video uh on me or something like
that, you know? He's [__] lying,
saying that I basically supported the
docs and that I'm basically ganging up
with a bunch of people that are
cryptodoxing him like Queen who's like,
>> "Yeah, like you you
has a life. Like, he has a wife. He
could go [__] go on a walk, buddy. Go
on a walk. I don't know. Go get Go get
an ice cream cone with your girlfriend.
I don't know what to tell you. You don't
have to be on Twitter arguing with these
people."
>> Dog whistling, calling for his dogs,
whatever the [__] that means. Completely
taking their arguments totally out of
context and just smearing them. And it's
he can get away with that because nobody
likes women, you know? He can get away
with that. I'm getting like so many
people in my comments and on Twitter
basically being like you pile around
with these [__] monsters like what
the [__] Like I I expected better from
you. He's painted it he's basically
painted them as mini bad empanadas. And
so now everyone thinks that I'm hanging
out with bad empanada basically through
this video. And then that last part when
he talks about like why I quit the
internet. First of all, I never told him
that's why I quit the [__] internet.
Now obviously the call that we had he's
referencing a call we had a month ago
where I had called him trying to ask him
to debate because I wanted to set up a
debate on my [__] channel. So I
called him. I was just shooting the
[__] right? I basically it was half
like set up the debate but also half
just to catch up with him and just see
cuz I haven't talked to him in a while
and so I call him or whatever and I'm
like hey man like I want to do a debate
between you and Queenman like I think
this could be really fun and he's
obviously giving me all his reasons why
he doesn't want to debate him and he's
rattling off you know speaking like
>> like dude if you just say no if you
don't want to debate someone just say no
just say no the fact that obviously he
could be you know Auggie could be
hyperbolic here I don't know Auggie I
never watched Auggie before okay I don't
know what he's like he could be being
hyperbolic but if he's being accurate he
was like hey do you want to debate
Queman and then he starts [__] spam
and verbally spamming these like excuses
as to why he why he can't debate Queman.
It's like, bro, that's so [__]
pathetic. A thousand words a second talk
about like how unfair they've been to
him, how they've like mistreated him and
stuff like that. And he's basically
talking about how their communities have
just been a giant [__] pain in his
ass. And so to relate with them cuz I'm
talking to him, I mentioned I'm like,
"Yeah, I know what it feels like to have
communities go after you." And I
mentioned like the Salvo thing and stuff
like that to sort of, you know, let them
know that like, "Yeah, I get where
you're coming from." But then when he
started explaining more and just going
off, you know, I start pushing back and
questioning. I'm like, "Well, how do
these communities really engage in this
sort of way? what are your problems?
Blah blah blah blah blah. And he gets
nervous and he's like, "Dude, are you
recording me?" And I'm like, "What the
fuck?" I like, "Hello." So I immediately
start screen sharing to prove it's like,
"Dude, this guy's [__] insanely like
this guy's like a paranoid loser. This
guy's like a paranoid loser." I saw
Auggie went live.
Oh, Dickers is still What is Dickers
even doing? He's not live. He's not
live. What is Odd Block doing? He got
exposed in a in a um in a Google
document,
right? Does anybody have this Google
document? Can we look at this Google
document
rig? Hello, Critical Shogun. Apparently,
uh Oplo got exposed. Apparently, if he's
responding to like the document's
probably bad if he's responding to it
like the first day, right? The day the
day it comes out.
But I'll look at this. I'll look at this
Auggie. Who cares? He's probably going
to have like How many views does he
have? 700. Yeah, I'm I think I'm fine. I
think I'm fine to stream snipe a little
bit. I have 40 viewers. I think we're
good. I think we're fine.
>> Stuff like this, right?
>> Since my last episode I did,
>> what is Gilded? I'm 30 plus. And yeah, I
don't think him flipping out over it
helped himself nor his wife. He should
have walked away and come back in a week
or two. Having a reaction is fine, but
acting on it is dumb. No, I I'm not 30.
I'm not I'm speaking out of line, so to
speak. But yeah, if you're if you are a
pushing 30, uh you should you should
know better.
You never respond to doc's. Don't touch
docs information. If you have like any
amount of integrity, um respect
someone's anonymity. if they want to be
anonymous, don't look at it. Uh, but the
moment the moment you like acknowledge
it, that basically opens the floodgates
cuz how I view doxing, if if the person
if if Willie never addressed his doxing,
you know, I would not have touched it. I
would never have talked about it. I
would I I didn't talk about it until he
started reacting to it, right? I didn't
talk about it until he started reacting
to it on Twitter because at that point,
he acknowledged it and he confirmed it
as real. So, at that point, it's like,
what are we supposed to do? Are we
supposed to just look at your tweet
saying, "Yeah, I do have a Jewish wife
and we're just supposed to like sit
there with our [__] in our hands. We're
not allowed to jerk off." Like, no. Come
on. Like, at that point, it's fair game,
I think. Yeah. He shouldn't have
reacted. That's like insanely reckless.
Especially if he was getting [__]
bomb threats, right? Confirming the
docs, confirming the docs on Twitter is
[__] insane. When you're when
confirming the docs, confirming where
you're going to get married, and then
complaining that you get threats, it's
like, dude, you did this. You put your
wife in plausible harm. You put your
wife in danger. You are literally using
her as a human shield. It's [__]
pathetic.
>> Uh I think two Fridays ago. Two Fridays
ago, I'm in quite a bit of trouble here.
And
>> has become a channel member.
>> Willie Max show, if you guys don't know,
has put out a hit piece on me, and
that's exactly what it is. Uh lying and
smearing not just me, but a couple other
people claiming that we justify
>> What is this background? Is this like a
basket?
Is this like a basket and a green lamp?
W background.
>> Uh his docks.
It's pretty much the main claim is that
we justified his docks. He said a lot of
nasty things about sympathy.
>> Look at his jawline. Did this guy lose
weight? Did he listen to the audience
>> for him that uh
>> Jesus
>> here? I'm just adjusting my audio. He
said, "I don't have any sympathy for him
getting doxed. He uh leaked private
conversations."
>> 567 has become a channel member.
>> He's gone hard against me. People in
chat are saying, "Wait, what?" Yeah, I
guess if you're not on Twitter, you have
no context as to what's happening. But,
uh, yeah, is very, very, very upset with
me.
>> And he put out this video. It was
disguised as like a bad empanada video.
And to be fair, he does talk a lot about
bad empanada, a lot of stuff with grout
and tea and stuff like that. Um, but he
spends a lot of time talking about me,
talked about my last section that I did
on him.
>> Has become a channel member
>> and it's absolutely [__] crazy. So,
we're going to go live. This is going to
be a bit of a shorter stream because I'm
just mainly just going to address this
just because I kind of have to. A lot of
people are curious on what I had to say
about this. I did call into Chudlogic's
show earlier and sort of expressed my
sort of free form thoughts on this whole
thing.
>> How does mor not know what a room
divider is? What are you dividing your
room up for? What are you dividing your
room up for?
>> Do a proper live dissection of the whole
video
of the whole video.
>> Dioro's days are numbered.
>> Okay. And I see a lot of people asking
me thoughts on Dioro not talking about
this. Look, here's the thing. Doro
called me last night and he told me two
things which is one of which is that hey
I didn't know that Willie was going to
do this to you
>> change your clothes
>> I had no idea Willie was making this
video
>> yeah Willy fashion show [__] fashion
show [__] you over no this is at
least as far as Dioro knows this is all
Willie this is all in Willy's mind
>> optimal has become a channel member IMA
celebrates 12 months of membership
Willie is the next yearly commentary to
get exiled from the community is next
>> well I don't think that's going to
happen um so yeah so Nick told me one
thing which is that he didn't know that
Willie was going to make this video on
me. Um, and he also told me that he's
not planning on covering this, right?
Which I mean, I knew exactly what was
going to happen. This was going to
infuriate the community. I guess a lot
of people are wondering why
>> and the truth is is like, look, I I
don't want to it's it puts me in a weird
position because I don't want to be in
this weird position where I'm like, "No,
Nick, you have to cover this." Because
it looks like I'm basically saying,
"Nick, you got to save me. You got to
[__] save my ass." Like, really
stomped on me. Like, please, Nick,
please help me and save me from this
whole situation. It's like I can cover
this on my own. I don't really need
other people to fight my battles for me.
Um, but I completely understand why
people are upset he's not covering it
because at the end of the day, I mean,
Willie did this video is very bad. This
video is very bad. It is pretty I'm
pretty comfortable saying this video
has outright lies about so many people
and their arguments, their intentions. I
mean, we'll play the video, the full
thing. We're not skipping a beat with
this video, but Willie is like he has
gone way off the deep end and I've seen
a lot of people
>> I want to see Tommy's reaction. No, I
want to look at Tommy C and uh food
shop's reaction because I think it'll be
very funny
>> after this though. He started he live 30
minutes ago. Yeah, I'm I'm 10,00%. I'm
gonna look at this.
I'll look at this a little bit. I don't
know if I'm gonna watch the entire
[__] stream. Okay. You didn't cover
Nick's response.
What is Nick's response? It's probably
going to be a [__] file that I have
to [__] Yeah, I have to [__]
convert it. Awesome.
Mov to MP4.
All right, I'll do that on the Because
I'm not fine with [__] smearing
people. That's what we consider going
off the deep end. Because I'm not I'm
not okay with [__] just smearing
[__] Clement and Jay- Sock as dirty
doctors and doing Destiny's [__]
dirty work, you know, celebrating and uh
rebroadcasting his [__] propaganda
that he's putting on all of his enemies,
saying that everyone that has an issue
with him is an evil [__] dirty doctor
while providing no [__] proof for
that. Because I have an issue with that.
That means that I'm, you know, dickr.
>> I'm going to mute these motives just cuz
I got a lot to say and I don't want
these things just like iring the stream.
But it's like we're going to sit here
and act like I'm the irrational one
because I'm not cool with just [__]
smearing people because they piss some
of my [__] friends off.
>> Okay? Because that's what I'm starting
to notice is going on in this community.
People are getting way too [__]
comfortable lying and just telling
stories that just aren't true about
people that they don't like, including
people that have done [__] things
towards them. I understand why Tommy is
mad at these people. I get why Willy's
mad at these people, but I'm not cool
suddenly just [__] lying about them,
>> you know?
>> I agree with that completely. I agree
with that completely. People are getting
too comfortable lying. I say that as a
liar. All right. I say that as a liar.
Okay. I say that as someone who has
lied. No point in watching food shops. I
mean, it's going to be funny to like
rage at. It's going to be funny to rage
at,
but I obviously there's not we're not
going to get some like immense value out
of it. Okay, I understand that. We're
not we're obviously not going to get
some immense value from watching food
shops content. And especially I'm not
cool with [__] rebroadcasting
Destiny's [__] narratives that
anyone that goes after him is part of
Queen and Jay- Socks doxing communities
when he has no [__] evidence except
for one guy that was caught sharing a
doc that was immediately [__] banned
as soon as Desi called that guy out. I'm
not going to [__] rebroadcast lies
and things that I know aren't [__]
true. Okay, I'm just never going to
[__] do that [__] And so anyone
sitting here thinking that I got blown
the [__] out? Well, I'm curious what
your opinion is going to be once we once
we finish watching this because this
video is a load of stinking [__] This
video is just I mean not just to be
clear not the whole thing the parts
where he says bad empanada is a horrible
doxer that's true bad empanata is a
horrible doxer bada dox willy and his
wife we don't like that in fact I was
disgusted obviously I mean do I have to
[__] say it
>> obviously I was disgusted
>> uh why about probably
>> so I have an extra response ready so we
can watch that in a little bit
>> when I was made aware that bad empanada
was doxing Willie and his wife and
trying to make their [__] wedding
hell okay obviously but here's the thing
right I'm not going to [__] go on
Twitter or go to my [__] show and
say, "Oh my god, bada dox will really
guys this is terrible because one, that
doesn't need to be said, but two, that
just brings more attention to the docs."
If I go on the air and I'm sitting here
telling everyone, "Guys, did you see bad
docs Willie? That's [__] horrible."
One, that's a worthless opinion because
it should be obvious that I think all
doxing is horrible. So, it's just a
waste of time to even say that. But two,
I'm hurting Willie in the process. I'm
making people more aware of it so that
anyone that's watching my streams that
doesn't really give a [__] about me or
Willie is like, "Oh, really? Will this
information out there?" Oh, well thanks
thanks Augie for letting me know where
exactly I can go to [__] find it, you
know? So it just makes no [__] sense.
So obviously this video like the parts
that he attacks bad I empanata on for
the most part from what I can tell seems
fair to me. Seems fair. It seems
accurate. It seems great. Here's the
problem though. We're not just calling
out bad empanada. This is not just a bad
empanada video. Willie has to include
other targets, other people.
>> Okay, I do feel I'm starting to feel bad
ripping this cuz he hasn't even gotten
any points yet. I'm just sitting here
[__] silent. I'm just sitting here
quiet. I'll watch like five more
minutes. If he doesn't get to it, I
think we'll move on because I just don't
I I don't want to I'm going to be
honest. I don't want to rip his [__]
content. I like Auggie. I don't want to
rip his stream. Even though I only have
like 50 viewers, I still think it's a
little shitty to do. So, unless he
doesn't if if he doesn't get to it. I
know he's a yapper. I know he's a
yapper. Um but if he doesn't get to it,
I think we'll move on and look at like
Dioro's response and stuff like that.
>> I've been pissing him off for months
now. People that have been really
getting under really grinding Willy's
gears. He's now comfortable with
smearing them and throwing them under
the bat and bananata umbrella, acting
like they have any part in this while
also showing no evidence that they do.
The arguments he makes in this video are
[__] laughable. And trust me, okay,
he criticized me for not watching the
original video that pissed him off.
We're going to watch it. But I think uh
you know, I can just sit here and just
yap or whatever, right? But we might as
well just play it. And like I said, I'll
play the whole thing. Okay. Now, I'm
mainly interested in the valid targets
section of the video, but I'll play the
whole thing. Whatever. Let's do it. Alex
says he has to include Destiny's enemies
and spread Destiny's narrative. Yeah,
exactly. And he's going to get into it
like why I uh I think he's upset that I
suggested that he might be controlled
opposition. I'll get into that too
because I have a very clear and [__]
frankly an obvious argument to make as
to why I said on my last show that
either Willy's [__] or he's
controlled opposition. I mean, that's
what Tommy said.
>> He is controlled opposition, right? No.
Again, this these are terms that like
nobody knows. These are terms that
nobody knows.
People don't understand what controlled
opposition is. When people hear
controlled opposition, uh, in their
minds they're like, "Oh, oh, he's he's
best friends with Destiny." No, that's
not what that means, right? No,
obviously not. That's not what that
[__] means. You're [__] That is
not what the term controlled opposition
means.
>> Covering this today. I I didn't watch
all of his coverage, but I tuned in a
little bit. And Tommy C is watching this
video. You want to talk about confused?
Tommy C is watching this video, and he's
sitting there. He's like, "Agi, if
you're going to call him controlled
opposition, you have to prove it." And
it's like Tommy, in the context of the
argument that I'm making, it's very
clear what I'm saying. But we'll get
into that. Trust me, we'll get into
that. But anyway, let's just start the
[__] video. Why not?
>> All right. All right. Sorry. Sorry.
We're going to normal speed this.
>> Benad is a known doctor and a harasser.
If you go on his Twitter account at any
time, you can see him doxing people.
He's probably the most famous for being
the one who claimed he called CPS on
Ethan and Hila. He's constantly
encouraged and defended people doing it.
He literally opened up a CPS merch line
because he thinks it's so funny.
>> Got a hat. I did CPS. The CPS logo with
the two skulls. Of course, two.
>> This merch is banger, by the way. I
don't understand. Like, this is
obviously a joke. Who cares? Why are you
Why are you like upset? This is
obviously a joke. Who cares? Banging
merch. I don't give a [__] This is
funny. Who cares?
>> Not a reference to anything in
particular.
>> He knowingly defames people. In my last
video, I pointed out that Banana Banana
constantly claims that Loner Box is dead
was part of a militia group that killed
>> I do want to see his response to like
when he starts talking about Auggie. So,
I'm going to skip ahead
or maybe the queen the queen line is
pretty bad.
The embassy gets shot and killed. She's
worried. So, I'm being told by the
police that I should go online and see
if there's any direct threats. And I see
a video made by a guy who hates me
showing all of my information and giving
a hypothetical where I'm a valid target.
Okay, here's the point.
>> Okay, what he should say here, all
right, what he should say here
is that Queman was obviously talking
about Destiny. He was not talking about
[__] Willie. He was talking about
Destiny being a [__] hypocrite. That
is what he should say here or something
along those lines.
>> Part of the video where we go crazy. So
again, we're at 6 minutes 30. Everything
I've seen so far has been pretty
reasonable in my opinion, right? It
seems fair. It's reasonable. It's
correct. It's valid. It's fine for him
to go after badaata is actually good and
based that he's going after badanata.
Badanata is a bad guy. Badanata is a
[__] [__] for what he did to
Willie. We're all in agreement here.
Okay, here's where we start to get
[__] nutty. Okay,
>> so I'm being told by the police that I
should go online and see if there's any
direct threats. And I see a video made
by a guy who hates me showing all of my
information and giving a hypothetical
where I'm a valid target because Destiny
is a hypocrite.
>> TV said anything involving this bad
empanada guy or anyone that supports him
is justifiable. Anything is justified
against Bad Empanada and anyone that
supports him. Let's apply those
standards. Why are we saying this about
Bad Empanada? Well, it appears to be
because Bad Empanada docks Willy Mack's
wife. So, would Destiny be saying that
those who dox people, those who make
calls to violence or illusions to
violence should be fair game? And all of
their supporters, all the personalities
that back him up, all the chats that
back him up,
>> this is essentially a Destiny snark
community. This guy's native of the past
six months is that I'm covering for
Destiny despite me making two of the
most in-depth videos.
>> Okay. Okay. Hold on. Before we get into
that, let's just watch the full segment
here. Because right off the bat, what
Willie is implying here is that Queen is
making an argument to sort of justify
doing whatever [__] up heinous [__]
you want to not just Destiny, but all of
his supporters.
>> Is that what Queen said? Is Queen going
on streams making justifications and
rationalizations for why you're allowed
to be a complete maniac towards Destiny
and his supporters, which is right.
>> Willie criticizes me in this video for
not watching the full queen clip. I
didn't know I needed to because I
thought the ark he was making was just
[__] brain dead obvious. But okay,
whatever. Let's watch the full clip.
This is posted uh this was posted well
this is like a different version of the
clip. This is weeks ago at this point.
Let's watch it. And people in chat are
saying so people in chat right now that
think I'm a [__] prick that think I'm
an [__] that think I'm team Hassan
that think I am pro Willy Mack getting
doxed are saying in the chat right now
Quimman is literally dog whistling to go
[__] with
>> I attended the wedding secretly and I
loved it. Okay. Thanks Tyrone. W Tyrone
W Tyrone. Destiny actually called my
death said he would he would kill me.
There was a moment to do me as well.
>> Sorry. Let's play this at one at one
time speed.
>> Destiny actually uh called to my death
said he he would he would kill me. There
was actually a moment in this video
shows Destiny attempting to dox me as
well. Obviously I'm not the
>> So Destiny said he wants to kill Queen.
He wants to doxman. He wants to do all
this horrible [__] to Queen. Kind of
sounds like bad empanada stuff. I don't
know if Willie has any comments about
that.
>> True. The only difference between bad
empanada and destiny is that one of them
is being alleged of sex crimes. That is
the only difference. But okay, let's
keep watching.
>> The only person this has happened to.
Now, something a little interesting. I
saw someone tweet out. A fellow by the
name of Little Steve tweeted something
very interesting out. Little Steve
Massa Stevie said, "Anything involving
this bad empanada guy or anyone that
supports him is justifiable. Anything is
justified against bad empanada and
anyone that supports him." Well, let's
apply those standards. Why are we saying
this about Bad Empanada? Well, it
appears to be because Bad Empanada docks
Willie Mac's wife.
So, would Destiny be saying that those
who dox people, those who make calls to
violence or illusions to violence should
be fair game? And all of their
supporters and all of their supporters,
okay? All the personalities that back
them up, all the chatters that back them
up, everything
are just everything against these
people. Anything is justifiable. That
seems to be the standard to me is that
anything no. Is that not the standard?
That's that's what he's laying out for
me here. Now I have principles. I have
principles. I don't think it's no bad
tactics, any bad targets. That's not me.
>> Okay. So Quan's making a very simple
argument, right? Which is that Destiny
engages in the same bad behavior that
Bad Panata does. No, let's be fair. I
think bad empanata is much much much
worse and more evil than Destiny. Okay,
let me just be clear here. But a lot of
the things Banana does on a regular
basis is behavior that Destiny is
starting to do especially a lot more
frequently right now. Right? So when
Destiny makes moralizing statements like
anything uh involving this bad empanada
guy or anyone that supports him is
justifiable, what Queen is saying is you
could say the same thing about him
because he engages in the same [__]
Right? But then he follows up with
saying that's not my standard.
>> That's the best nuke.
>> That that's not my standard. But you can
say that about him.
>> Very [__] simple argument to follow.
Let's keep watching the clip because
something happens.
>> That's not me.
>> But Destiny is very clearly laying out
that those are the standards that he
believes in. Those are the standards he
he wishes to be enforced. is if you're a
doctor, if you call for violence,
anything is justifiable against you
supporters.
>> Order taken.
>> So, somebody donates, one of Clement's
fans donates and says, "Got it. Order
taken."
>> They're either making a joke or they're
saying, "Oh, haha, I understand the dog
whistle, blah, blah, blah." And then
Clement responds.
>> Okay, that's not what I'm saying, Max.
Actually, I just explicitly said
otherwise, actually, Max,
>> he says, "No, no, no, no. That's not
what I'm saying. Just to be clear here,
right?" However, he's making the mortal
sin here of grinning and laughing. He's
making the mortal sin of grinning and
laughing, which Willie Max show is going
to take as evidence that this whole
entire video. Play the clip. Play the
clip. Laugh at somebody saying something
[__] up. That means that is signaling
to his chat. You guys get it, right? And
that's the argument that we're making.
And that's the argument that really this
whole section of Will's video rides off
of. That's the argument that we're going
off of here is that this video is a dog
whistle and a tacid endorsement of doing
[__] up [__] to Destiny and all of
Destiny supporters, which includes
Willie. That is the good faith
interpretation of Willy's argument.
Well, I'm sorry, dude, but I think that
that's [__] paranoid, schizophrenic
[__] And I just cannot for the life
of me watch this [__] clip and sit
here and act like that's a good [__]
argument. Okay, if somebody comes in my
chat, let's say somebody comes in my
chat right now and is like, I'm going to
blow up Willy Mack with
>> He is a bit of a yap. Get to the clip.
Can we get to the clip? Has he not even
watched the clip yet? He hasn't. Okay,
he hasn't even watched the clip yet.
This Listen, I'm not going to keep
stream sniping. I I I I feel bad. I feel
bad uh stream sniping. If you want to go
watch his streams, you can go watch his
streams. Um I'm probably going to watch
it off off stream or maybe if he
finishes if he finishes stream while I'm
streaming, I can go back and watch it.
Uh, but I don't want to uh I I feel bad.
I feel bad. I feel like I'm not adding
much because I don't have really a lot
to say. I just agree with him. So, this
is uh Nicholas Dioro's
response to the Willie video.
>> All right. Now, uh why about probably
six of you are in the stream. I just
wanted to briefly talk about this Willie
Mac Show drama. Uh because obviously I
have to because it's it's it's what's
been requested upon me by everyone. Uh I
I made it pretty clear that I didn't
really want to do the interpersonal
drama. [__] a couple of weeks ago and up
until this point,
but inevitably I I think that people
really want answers to every every
individual stupid question. So, I'll
just say I told Willie Matt show that he
should just drop this and he should stop
um
he should just leave. He should just
stop fighting with
>> like Listen, I I don't know if I'm being
unfair. If you're going to address it,
just [__] watch the video. Just watch
the video. You should be allowed to
criticize your friends. You should be
allowed to criticize your friends. You
should be allowed to be critical of your
friends. Listen, I'm gonna be real. If
Becket burned the bridge with me, right?
Legitimately burned the bridge with me
because of the [__] I was saying about
him uh and and me being critical of him
and me expressing my opinion about what
he was going through and doing and
whatever. I think that would be insanely
[__] pathetic. Insanely mindn
numbingly pathetic. But he didn't. Okay,
he didn't. Say what you want about
Becket. Say what you want about him
being friends with Lio. say what you
want about him, you know, maybe having a
bit of a double standard or or a bit of
an inconsistency or whatever. Okay.
Uh he he's he's fine being friends with
people who are critical of him. He's
fine being friends with Quean. He's fine
being friends with Chud. Uh being
friends with me. Again, I say friends
loosely. These are like internet
friendships. Uh internet friendships are
very different from like in real life
intimate friendships. Just to be clear,
I'm not like close person with this guy.
I I DM him maybe like once a month,
okay? I do not talk to Becket a lot.
Uh, but I I do respect him and yeah, I I
respect that he's not just like if if
people [__] on him, he's just like
running away or like I'm not going to
talk to you anymore. Like yeah, I think
that that's [__] [__] if you do that,
which is seemingly what Willy's doing
with like Chudlo Logic and all these
people, right?
>> With these people and in retaliation, a
video came out talking all about these
people. So, at that point, there's
really not much I can say or do. I I I
gave him my opinion. um
he did the opposite. So now I think that
him and Auggie are going to fight a lot
and I I'm I'm rooting for uh you to get
as much content as you want out of it.
Ultimately though, I think it's just
kind of going to end up being a slap
fight now. I think Willie has brought up
stuff about like Auggie leaving over
comments made about [__] I guess
Auggie's mom. And obviously Willie is
just coming back from getting docked at
his wedding and his wife getting put
everywhere. Uh, and at this point, my
understanding of how this is going to
move forward from here is I think that
everyone's just going to be awful.
I think that um I I think we're entering
like the technical stage of the feud
where at this point there's probably not
going to be he cannot think in absolute
everything has to be a comparison to
something happened something that
happened previously. Okay.
Everything has to be like dude it's it's
like it's like this thing that happened
years ago. It's like this thing that
happened a while ago, guys. This is
exactly like this other drama. Wow.
[__] [__] dude. Sign of low IQ.
>> Any ground covered here. I think these
guys just kind of got to slug it out for
a couple of weeks and get tired and then
maybe they can reach some kind of common
ground. Maybe they won't. Um, but it
doesn't really seem like anybody is
moving into this discussion looking to
have a um a beautiful productive
dialogue. It just seems like from here
everybody's going to start sideswiping
each other. Uh, listen, I've had to put
multiple friends down over the years.
You guys gather around every every
summer to watch Nicholas Dioro come
through and assassinate another friend
so you can tell me all for the next six
months about what a huge piece of [__]
backstabber I am up until the point
where the next friend says two words out
of line and all of a sudden it's banging
down the door to go make me talk about
it again. I think the commentary
community can probably handle this one
on their own. I I reached out to Auggie
yesterday because I retweeted the video
like
>> this is
why even [__] reference it? Why even
address it then? You should be policing
the community that you're a part of,
right? My friend Marcus, who I've known
for two years, almost two and a half
years, I think, if I'm correct. I'm
going to be critical of him. I'm going
to self police in that way. If he does
something [__] I'm going to talk
about it. This guy is like the the
person I've known longest in this space.
Literally the longest time I've ever
known someone in this space, it has been
Marcus. And yeah, I'm gonna be critical
of him. Just because I'm friends with
this guy, just because I know him
doesn't automatically mean that I'm that
he's somehow like, you know, void of
being, you know, able to be critical of
or or or whatever the [__] the term
would be. I don't know. It's just like
this mindset is so [__] like stupid.
It's so stupid. It's so stupid. You can
never be critical of your friends. You
can never self police. You can never do
this. You can never do that. It's like,
bro,
I don't know.
I want a community
I want a community where you are allowed
to be critical of people that you like.
I want a community where you're allowed
to be critical of your friends. I want a
community where people don't feel like
they're burning the [__] bridge with
me by being critical of my video to the
point where they lie to me and tell me
that the videos I put out are [__]
perfect when they have glaring issues
that could have been fixed if they were
honest. It's like, bro, this people
people act like this this community that
they forged where you're not critical of
your friends is somehow beneficial
because like, oh, you're being nice. No,
you're not. You're encouraging people to
do worse. You're not encouraging people
to be better. You're not encouraging
people to, you know, make better
content, whether that be videos or
streams or takes or [__] tweets even.
You're you're you are encouraging
mediocrity. It is so [__] lame.
It is so [__] lame. So [__] lame.
Bad empanada when I was at like a
wedding and I wanted Auggie to know that
like I'm not like I it wasn't like a I
didn't even watch it. I just saw bad
empanada. Um yeah. So that's cool.
I wish you both luck in your forever
war. So chat thinks I'm pro Hassan and
tells me Oh yeah. Well, I mean half this
community thinks that I'm just like a
Ethan Klein dick sucker or whatever.
Ultimately it's it's whatever it's
whatever ongoing narrative is. I feel
bad for you. Uh, there's one thing I did
want to show, and this is probably the
main thing that's kind of annoyed me in
this entire situation, is just hearing
the the newest, most recent clip of
Destiny for some reason really caring
about this like a lot. Um,
>> and he goes on to like talk about
[__] It's like, bro,
>> you should be policing. Like, I I I find
this
>> I don't know. I mean, I've said this
before, so at this point, you guys have
heard this [__] 10 billion times.
This is not nothing new. But yeah, this
is just spineless cowardly behavior.
This sucks.
But trust me, guys, tr look at Mudahar.
Look at Boaxs. The moment the tides
shift, the moment the tides shift, this
is going to go away. The moment the
tides shift against Willie, he'll start
talking about him on stream. Okay? He
will go after safe targets even if they
are his friend. The moment the tides
shifted on Mudahar, started going after
Mudahar. the moment the tides shifted on
Boaxs started going after Boaxs. Okay,
obviously I'm being a bit hyperbolic,
okay? You know what I mean? Uh I do
think I do genuinely believe once the
tides shift once maybe not once if the
tides shift uh he will start going
pretty or or harder at least at Willie.
I do believe that. I do think that
honesty is good but can be difficult
with friends sometimes. Okay, YouTube
friends are more akin to like co-orker
friends, right? Like maybe you play
games sometimes but you're not super
intimate. Maybe you get to know each
other. Maybe it turns into like a real
friendship. Who knows? But it's it's
more akin to co-workers. Like yeah, you
should be you should be cordial, but you
should you should be honest. I feel like
you should be honest.
When I was a [__] manager at a
restaurant at the [__] steakhouse or
whatever the [__] I worked at. All
right. When I was a manager, if an
employee came up to me and was like,
"Hey, am I doing a good job?" And they
weren't doing a good Yeah. I'd be
honest. I'd be like, "No, you're you're
kind of [__] up. Try to speed up. You
know, you know, wash dishes a little
quicker. Like, you're you're you're
taking a little too long on this or, you
know, you're try to be a little more
nice to customers. Try to do [__]
whatever." It's like, no, just don't
don't don't encourage mediocrity, I
guess, is the is the whole thing here.
All right. Should we watch food shops
now? What else is there to cover? What
else is there to cover?
Should we watch food shops?
Food shops are Tommy C.
because I feel like there's not much
more to
look at in terms of that. I don't want
to I don't want to rip the Augie stream.
I'm I'll watch it off stream, I think.
Okay, she has a VOD.
Willy M declares war on Queen and Jtock.
It's 25 minutes. Instead of watching the
entire stream, I think we'll just watch
this. I've made videos on communists,
Nazis, misogynist, feminists, scammers,
and traffickers. People with millions of
followers, yet this tiny little
community is where all this doxing takes
place and it's just out of their heads.
Dude, they're obvious.
>> You never watched Tina covering food
shops or you never watch food shops
covering Tina's interview. It was full
of horrible takes. Um, maybe I'll watch
that. Not today.
Maybe if we like are on the bottom of
the barrel and we run out of [__]
completely. Sure.
>> Obviously feeding into it. But Auggie
knows nothing. He can't even recite me
goofing on them accurately. Jar,
>> I don't, dude. Well, I mean, like I I
think that Auggie Augi is just [__] me,
dude. Wait, did Auggie actually was Did
Auggie ever had a handle on things in
the first?
>> Did Auggie ever had a handle on things?
This person's first language was
English, right? Am I Or are they like a
immigrant?
Okay, I can't insult someone's speech. I
I [__] up all the time. No, that's
that's unfair. That's on me. That's
unfair. That's on me.
>> First place. [__] Like like is Auggie
like um
m maybe maybe Auggie never had
like maybe Auggie never had any handle
in the first place. Who the [__] knows?
>> Criticized Destiny for creating a
metaphorical rape machine partially
because he had sex with BPD girls. Then
when these girls call him out for being
abusive, everyone thinks they're just
crazy. Jtock then had sex with the same
BPD girl. Everything Destiny is saying
here is true.
>> True.
>> And he does not he does not substantiate
this with a clip. And they're just going
to say true.
>> Yes. True.
>> That is not true. That is not it's
obviously not the criticism. Clip is
provided to substantiate that.
Uh-oh.
Uhoh. Hold on. Look at that. W
replacement of gameplay. W replacement
of gameplay. All right.
>> Yeah, JT stuck [__] trickle down
[__] like cherry. Yes.
>> Actually, it's not true. Actually,
everything Destiny is saying here is
complete [__] Desi says, "And to
think that this was the same guy, Juck
Juicealker, who spent the last year
saying having sex with mentally ill
people equals rape. Crazy, huh?" No, you
[__]
>> That was never the argument that you
have sex with mentally ill people, that
means you're raping them by default. The
argument is that you don't give a about
their consent because you'll share their
images, videos of them doing all kinds
of sexual stuff. You'll share that with
anyone.
>> No, Auggie. JTO actually specifically
said it's not about sharing images.
>> I think that the main talking point is a
Destiny distribution.
>> Yeah. They just don't show a clip
>> and like they're not going to be
critical of this at all. They're not
going to be critical of this at all,
>> but you know, whatever. Whatever. No
clip is shown to substantiate, but
whatever. Sure. or whatever food shop.
Sure.
>> I I think that's not the same the the
main talking point. I think one of the
big I mean a massive talking point here
is the infinite rate machine. Okay. How
does the infinite rate machine work?
It's a massive talking point which you'd
know if you're
>> the infinite rate machine
>> part of the if you watch the Sunday
video.
>> Does Okay. Are they also do they also
not know what the infinite rate machine
is?
>> This it's not just about nudes, bro.
It's about a system that let this happen
for so long.
>> And what does Sunday say? Part of the
machine is destiny targeting mentally
ill women and the victims are also
selected either for mental illness
allowing them to be easily
>> oh god present Sunday. Okay. Epic Reddit
epic Reddit moderator. Okay. [__]
Oh.
>> Okay. Do they actually disagree with
anything? Do they actually like disagree
with anything? Do they actually
disagree? Do they they have anything to
say about this? Do they have anything to
say about this?
Do they have a disagreement here?
I I need to turn the audio off actually
so you guys you guys don't hear the
[__] audio. Um
>> there we go. Is there a disagreement
here that you have? Are you going to say
anything to President or are they just
lay Reddit mod? Are they just lay Reddit
mod?
>> Just all the worst people into like one
video. Okay. Okay, it's all the [__]
most worst [__] Listen, I I don't
even I don't even I don't even feel any
obligation to defend um Willy Mack.
Okay, I'm pretty sure Willy Mack called
me a pedto.
You called yourself that.
You called yourself that. Whatever.
Whatever, man. Whatever, man.
Listen,
you called yourself that.
You did. You did. You called yourself
that.
Food shops. You did. You called You
called yourself a pedophile. You called
yourself a pedophile.
But whatever. Cool. All right.
Yeah,
>> construed as hysterical or deceptive
when they complain about their
treatment. So, when it leaks that JTO is
having a secret relationship with the
same BPD girl and she crashes out on him
multiple times, it's funny. I'm giving
him [__] I'm allowed to talk [__] back
to these people. I talked to Auggie
about the same exact thing a month ago
and told him if he wanted to find it,
you could just watch the ending to my
second Destiny video. But he didn't
watch it. He'd rather make stuff up.
Bro, you're sitting at a computer right
now. Feel free to use it. Auggie ends
this hourong. By the way, congrats on
the seventh day on 100 plus concurrent.
Yeah, but it's not in a row. I think
I've had several days. Um I think I had
like three days or four daysish. No, I
think like three days where I was like
hovering around
uh 70 to 95ish.
But yeah, thank you. I appreciate that.
Anyway,
donate, okay? Please, please support
your humble local content creator, okay?
Thank you. All right. Please. I need to
have a louder voice. I need to be able
to clash with people. Thank you.
>> You're not even cl You're not You're not
I need to be able to clash with people.
You're not doing anything. You're not
doing anything.
>> On me summarizing that the only reason
I'd be mad is because I'm stupid or
because Destiny controls me, feeding
into the narrative that got me doxed in
the first place.
>> It's hard to like logically understand
why he's posting this [__] I mean, the
two options is literally just he's like
brain dead [__] right now or he's
controlling it. It
>> It's actually kind of insane like how
confident Auggie is, isn't it?
>> [__] He's just so confidently wrong.
>> Confidently wrong about what? What do
you do? Huh?
>> Posting this [__] I mean, the the two
options is literally just he's like
brain dead [__] right now or he's
control it. It
>> It's actually kind of insane like how
confident Augie is, isn't it?
>> Wait, I'm so What are you saying?
because I'm stupid or because Destiny
controls me, feeding into the narrative
that got me doxed in the first place.
>> It's hard to like logically understand
why he's posting this [__] I mean, the
two options is literally just he's like
brain dead [__] right now or he's
controlling it.
>> It It's actually kind of insane.
>> Yes, he is [__] Wrong about what? He
is [__] for confirming his docs.
What? Hi. Okay.
Okay. Okay.
>> Saying like how confident Auggie is,
>> isn't it?
>> Yeah.
>> [__] He's just so confidently wrong.
>> Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep.
>> He's just so confidently [__]
>> Yep. Yep.
>> Opposition.
>> That's all you could think of? Well, let
me give you a third option. Our wedding
is having to prepare for fake bomb
threats and my bride is worried about us
and our family getting shot. Auggie
never wants spring mind. Seriously, if
that's the extent of your analysis, you
need to quit. In my last conversation
with Auggie, he told me a story.
>> Bro, bro, bro, bro, I need to know the
full Fallout story. Okay, I need
>> the Fallout the Fallout 2 story. Gulp
>> story of of what happened between these
two that made them fall out like this
because this sounds like this sounds
personal. Okay,
>> what fallout here?
There's no one in front.
Okay. Okay.
>> I'm not going to lie. This does sound
This feels personal to some degree.
Okay.
>> Story about how he quit drama for a year
because a guy named Salvo was doxing and
harassing him and his family. So, where
is that same sympathy when it's
happening to me and my wife? He shares
the same empathy meter with Ian.
>> You know, my empathy meter's only maybe
like a quarter of the way filled up.
Most reassuring news I got was when my
wedding planner told me that she talked
to the venue.
>> That is hypocritical. If true. That is
hypocritical. I'm assuming that's true.
All right. Because this is such an
easily fact check thing that like it's
it's just so easy to disprove Willie
Macro. But like if this is not the case,
Salvo Pancakes, I think, was doxing
Augie.
And they told her that the riff raff
doesn't bother them because they've done
celebrity weddings and that they're in a
Jewish neighborhood. So they're used to
getting calls like this. In one sense,
very reassuring because it means our
venue wasn't spooked. And in another
sense, very depressing because Auggie
has always been [__] since technical
destroyed on Keemstar's show. Wait, then
why is he so celebrated? Like if Auggie
is such a [__] like why the [__] is
he so celebrated by the com? Is it just
because everyone else is also a [__]
It means people are just calling and
harassing this place because they're in
a Jewish neighborhood. I don't know what
should happen when it comes to Destiny
or his Snark community doxing each other
and others. But what I do know is Bad
Empanada needs to be banned. He non-stop
slanders people, doxes people, and
harasses them. He recently swatted Kraut
by falsely reporting him to the Austrian
police for hacking his alt Twitter
accounts. I don't think they were ever
hacked at all.
>> He accuses me of hacking. Bad panada
accuses me of hacking specifically.
>> What is wrong with these people? Dude,
[__] me, dude. You know what? You know
what? based. All right. I think everyone
should just start doxing each other. All
right. [__] Dox, too. Okay. [__] Do
it.
>> Okay. I I think everyone should start
doing it so that nothing is private. So
then So then when we say something, we
actually Okay.
>> So then when we say something, we're
putting everything on the line for it.
Okay. [__] it. All right. That's how
things should be. Yes.
>> He accuses me of hacking 15 of his
banned Twitter accounts.
>> His evidence of Crouch hacking him comes
from a tweet where Crouch says he's
archiving his accounts. That's literally
it.
>> This here is the central claim. He
claims, "I got illegal access to 15 of
his 22 temporarily banned ex accounts."
Well, what did I tweet? I tweet, "Yeah,
we managed to get archive files
containing everything bad and panatada
tweeted with 15 of his 22 suspended
accounts." Well, how did we get this? We
went to Wayback Machine and typed in his
accounts.
>> So, obviously,
it's is not you hacking him. He's saying
that that tweet is evidence that he was
hacked.
>> Yes,
>> Badam Panata actually just uploaded a
video on why he thinks his police report
was justified and in it he just reads
his complaint.
>> So, this is probably the most serious
thing that he did and that he publicly
implied that he had hacked my um social
media accounts and obtain private
information about me that is otherwise
inaccessible from doing so and that he
was going to go through it and share it.
>> Hey, no neck. He's talking about the
public tweets you posted. Oh yeah, this
tweet where Crouch says he's going to
screenshot the unhinged stuff I say.
Yeah, that's evidence he's going to hack
me. Please believe me, audience. Like,
how stupid are his viewers?
>> An archive file containing everything
bad empanada tweeted with 15 of his 22
suspended accounts. Now, you can't
really get an archive file of someone
else's Twitter. The only way you can get
the Twitter archive file is by having
access to the account. So, that's very
suspicious, isn't it?
>> Or he could just go to your public
Twitter page and screenshot all your
tweets. He's so desperate to sound like
a victim here when he's the one who
falsely swatted crowd.
>> He didn't want me to think that he
engaged in potentially criminal
activity. Why did he make public post
implying that he was engaged in
>> First of all, again, this wasn't
swatting. This wasn't swatting. Swatting
is a very specific term. Swatting is a
very specific term where you call I
don't even want to fight. Dude, I have
to fight the [__] ants. I hate the
fighting the ants. I just want to skip
this.
Okay.
Swatting. SWAT is a very specific term
where you lie to the police.
You lie to the police to incite a SWAT
team uh or you know armed forces to go
to your [__] house uh to do whatever.
Right?
That is what a swatting is.
So no what bad empanada did was not
swatting. He filed a police report,
which filing a false police report is
still bad, but swatting someone is
significantly worse. Swatting someone is
significantly worse, right?
So, I I I
don't know. This is just [__]
[__]
Like, no, he did not swat anyone. You
should not. Okay, here's my take on Bad
Empanada. I think bad empanada is bad. I
think he's done some bad stuff. I think
he deserves to be criticized. Uh and and
and whatever, right?
However, I don't think you should be
lying about him, lying about what he's
doing, lying about what he's done, uh
lying about what he, you know, whatever.
Lying about him at all. Uh because that
just gives him more leeway, right? That
helps him. Lying about bad empanata does
not hurt him. Lying about bad empanata
helps him, right?
But sure, I guess you caught it sliding
[__] lie about him. Make it easier
for him to get away with this [__]
Whatever. Cool.
>> In that activity public post that
clearly the Vienna police who
investigated the case thought were
suspicious. I'm pretty sure I watched a
video where um it was exposing crop for
like spreading misinformation and trying
to like be a propaganda propagandist for
the liberal side honestly based but at
the same time
I feel like I just can't view Crot the
same anymore. I would say like his best
video I would say like Crot's best video
was Chsky the the Chsky one was his best
video and that's about it
>> enough to warrant an investigation and
an interview. What bad empanada is not
telling you is that the police dismissed
his complaint as having zero merit. He's
essentially reading his own complaint
and then acting like that somehow makes
it more legit. It doesn't. This is only
a small portion of how stupid this
police report is. In short, the police
closed the investigation because it was
a massive waste of time. But this still
allowed Bad Panata to get all of Crowd's
personal information. When the police
closed the investigation, Badam Panata
wrote an email threatening Crowd to stay
silent on it.
>> Hi, Joseph. I did not swore you. You
gave me legitimate reason to believe
that you were hacking my accounts.
>> Yeah. And then and then the thing is is
that Bad Epanada then acts like a
[__] like second rate third rate
anime villain. Okay. Like he can't he
tries to do this like little villain
monologue all the [__] time and he
tries to act like a badass. It's so
[__] cringe. Like it sounds like he
never got past his [__] puberty
stages of like being addicted to the
puberty like Sasuke or some [__] like
like he he thinks he's actually like
someone who's so [__] badass. Oh god.
>> In an attempt to divulge my
>> isn't cross saron dick suck. I genuinely
>> don't think so anymore at the very least
if he was that in the first place.
Yeah
>> private information and posted very
public threats against me. I'm relieved
to hear that you apparently denied that
you were really engaging in this
behavior. I will not apologize for
taking basic measures to protect myself,
like filing a police report when you
public Oh god. And then and then
President Sunday does this too. He does
like the [__] fake gigachad thing
where where he pretends that he's
actually more masculine than he actually
is.
>> President Sunday is gay. How how how
more masculine can you get?
President Sunday is literally gay.
President Sunday's gay. Okay, that's
masculine. That's masculine. That's
epic.
>> And he tries to sound like a [__]
like manly intellectual
um stereotype person. Oh my god. God,
these people are so cringe. Get me out
of this space, dude. Jesus.
>> You can leave, buddy.
>> I feel like I feel like I'm just
tripping out every single time. Um,
every single time I'm interacting with
this space because I just can't believe
how unfathomably cringe everyone is.
>> Made such statements. I would prefer to
not have to talk about this publicly as
you will note that I have refrained from
doing up until this point because I
legitimately never skip the queen
to you and have no wish to embarrass or
divulge any personal info by releasing
any of the files I received from the
public prosecutor's office on this case.
Or in other words, stay silent or I'm
going to post all of your personal
information I got from the police. Crowd
has vented a bit about this. So bad
empanada has already started lying about
the facts. Crowd is currently going
around claiming that I swatted him. In
reality, I reported him to the Vienna
police because he was
>> okay. Again, to be I think I think terms
are important. I think terms are
important. Yes. Don't say that he
swatted anyone. Don't say that.
>> Lying about Bad Empanada helps him. You
are helping bad empanada. You are
helping him by lying about him. Dumb
[__] Holy [__]
But whatever. Whatever.
>> He was stalking doxing me for months.
The prosecutor thought the evidence I
provided was suspicious enough to
warrant an investig.
>> Ah, yes. The cherry the cherry method of
of um claiming that you filed a police
report and and said that you were
completely serious about it. Ah, yeah.
>> Do they think that Cherry lied about
filing a police report? What?
What?
Oh my god.
Oh.
Oh my [__] god. All right. Based
based actually.
based actually
WW and W and Epic pill I guess.
>> Yes. Yes. I totally I totally had uh
Yeah, the the police did indeed think I
think that um there warrants enough
investigation and enough evidence to
warrant some kind of concern going on.
Especially Austrian police are obligated
to investigate every report and the
investigation came back saying bad
empanada had little more than
circumstantial evidence that his
accusations of violent threats can both
in objective and subjective manner not
be proven due to there not being any
violent threats. That the accusation of
liel or slander is not detectable. This
video is so embarrassing by him. He is
non-stop lying. And from what I've seen,
Bad Empanada has no evidence. He's just
wasting everybody's time to get a doc.
Seriously, how is this guy not banned
from everything? There is some good news
though. Bad empanada is apparently on
the run. I thought it was just a meme
when he posted today's stream is delayed
as I am fleeing to a different country,
but it turns out this might be real as
Ethan is monologuing his next move to
track him down. Bad empanada is on the
run. He knows we're closing in. We
suspected he had fled back to Australia.
But upon further research and
verification, he's actually fled to
Uruguay. This information is probably
shocking for him to hear as he went to
great lengths to obscure his escape from
Argentina to Uruguay. Madame Banata, if
you ever decide to return to Australia,
we'll be immediately notified and a
torrent of lawsuits will follow. You are
easy to get in Australia, which is why
you're doing everything to avoid
returning. Why am I telling you this?
So, he looks over his shoulder every
day. We are coming and we will win. You
can run from us, but we are
>> Okay, hold on. It's food. Okay, food
shops, criticize them for doing the
gigachad monologue. Criticize them. Come
on. Come on. You critic you hated it
when when President Sunday did it. Come
on. Come on. Do it. Do it. Do it. You
hated it for bad empanada. Do it. Do it.
>> Touch you and we will ruin you. Have a
nice day.
>> Bad empanada chimed in. Does it feel
good to be hated live? Literally
everywhere you are.
>> First of all, bad empanada.
>> You're an outcast from society.
Like we live in Los Angeles, California.
You are on the run.
>> I mean, you know you're a piece of [__]
when even his son pulls up bad and
panata's video of him doxing me and even
he's surprised about what's happening.
Just like how I can tell you that Willie
Msho is William McConville and um he is
getting married to a Yale. Now I am not
going to give you the full name of um
the person he's getting married to, but
I can tell you she is Israeli and she
was assigned to him by
>> Bestis Gibb to be honest.
This is drama slob and banana content.
Yeah, I don't really give a [__] about
this.
>> Like I appreciate that he stopped
watching immediately, but why are we
acting like it's just slop? I'd argue
it's a bit more ill intended than slap
content. Assan is a guy who thinks these
subreddit LSF posting his stream clips
quantifies as stalking and harassment.
>> If I was a smart person, I wouldn't be
getting ritualistically humiliated by
socially maladjusted freaks that are
agorophobic on a daily basis in a mass
harassment campaign online. But I do
that for a living.
>> The song casually watching a doc more
than that. Like, dude, if you're
watching a doc or you stand by doxing
your opponent's, fine. All right, but
he's he's acting as if like that
empanada didn't just like dox someone.
>> Hey, how are you? Oh my god, dude. Holy
[__] Yeah, that's how you're supposed
to act. If you don't want to spread a
dox, then you should, you know, be like,
"Oh, this is weird." And then [__]
stop watching it. Don't drag attention
to it. What do you want him to do? Holy
[__] This bad guy just docked someone.
How many viewers does Assan get like on
average, dude? How many how many people
aren't really paying attention that
much? Like, yeah, that that should be
how you react to like docs if you've
accidentally stumbled upon someone,
right? Don't look at it. Don't
acknowledge it. Just kind of back away,
right? That that is the correct
response. What Hassan did there is like
perfectly fine.
>> Did that not just happen?
>> My personal just drama slop. Then he
watches him again a few days later.
Empanada is a good good example of this
where I think he's like a crazy person.
>> Uh he is a chaotic good if that makes
sense.
>> No, it doesn't. Please
>> what? Please tell me you didn't call the
bad epic chaotic good. He is actually
the very definition of chaotic evil. But
okay,
>> explain
>> like think about that's
again these people just don't know
definitions. Chaotic good is someone who
does who has a good end goal. What bad
empanada believes he's doing is good
obviously, right? He he's like he's he
believes he's anti- genocide.
I don't know enough about Israel
Palestine to know if he actually is
anti-genocide. I don't really give a
[__] But yeah, chaotic good is like a
fine term to use.
He thinks he's he is doing something for
a good end goal, right?
If someone docks you, remember no, they
didn't. Yeah. Don't acknowledge docs as
ever is like the rule essentially. Don't
[__] touch that [__] If someone
else's gets docs, don't touch it. Don't.
It's just like, yeah, it's it's good
courtesy to not acknowledge someone's
[__] docks when they get doxed.
>> About how little I I uh think about how
little I little time I spend like on bad
emp
>> I think he's coming from like we have
different methods. We have different uh
tactics. We have different techniques.
>> His tactics are doxing, false police
reports, false CPS reports, slandering
people constantly.
>> But uh overall uh we're working on the
same side. Hassan is literally saying he
supports what Bad Empanada is doing.
Like Hassan clearly knows at this point
who Bad Empanada really is. He literally
had a one-on-one conversation with him
where Bad Empanada said these people
deserve to be harassed. Meaning anyone
who mildly disagrees with them.
>> Be mean to them. If they feel if they
feel bad, if they feel harassed honestly
>> good,
>> great. I don't give a
>> There you go.
>> Each and every one of them. We need to
be mean to these guys. We need to be
[__] They deserve it. He knows the
guy he's supporting is doing this and
purposely promotes him. Anyway, a week
passes and they're ping out about my
docs and pedaling.
>> Just a reminder that Hassan literally
disavowed bad Epanata in the past until
it was convenient for him. Okay, so you
know, just FYI,
>> he continues to call him good Epanata to
chaotic good Ganon. Oh my
>> lies about my wife to discredit valid
criticism about them. They're just
trying to assassinate my character.
>> You're just doing uh investigative
journalism. They're saying Banipanata
unearthed that. Is that true?
I think bad or one of somebody somebody
unearthed like the the willy
>> dude can you just imagine like naming
everything that Destiny does to be
investigative journalism when he doxes
people or something dude I feel like I
feel like um the Shia commentary would
literally go insane um from from like
seeing that excuse no investigative
investigative journalism in
>> yeah it's not investigative journalism
does that make what Destiny's doing like
okay no obviously not investigative
journalism. Uh, you know what? That's
why I'm going to call all all doxing
from now on. It's it's investigative
journalism, guys.
It's fine. It's investigative. It it do
be investigating. You know,
>> Mac shows getting married to like a IDF
lady or something,
>> which makes sense. He was the guy who
did the the big expose on on like you
with the Ali bombing hospital.
>> Probably one of the best minds in
politics right now. truth. So yeah,
compromise.
>> Like man, I just keep forgetting. You
could justify any
>> Wait, hold on. Did Hassan just glaze
that epanata on the information that
that epanata has doxed? Will the [__]
>> I couldn't have heard that correctly,
right? Like
>> somebody assassinate my character.
>> You're just doing
>> no journalism.
>> You're saying Banana unearthed that. Is
that true?
I think bad or one of somebody somebody
unearthed like the the Willie Mac shows
getting married.
>> Notice that they're using every single
word in the English lexicon that is a
synonym for like docs, right?
>> Yeah, we understand
>> investing. So is what Destiny did bad is
what Destiny did bad by amplifying the
docks. Maybe. Maybe is what Destiny did
bad. Food shops. Maybe. Have you thought
about that? Have you considered that
angle?
>> Journalism. They know what they're
doing. They This shows intent. This
shows that they know. They know.
>> This shows that they know.
>> Martini, shaken, not stirred.
>> I'm here to support her investigative
journalism.
>> Hey, thank you so much, Masaki. Thank
you so much for the 10 Australian guys.
Yes, be like Msaki. Okay, donate.
Contribute to your local streamer. Okay,
we need all the support that we can get
for this I I don't want to say culture
war, but like this internet war, I
guess. One night joker, where's the foot
cam? Thank you so much for the 163, but
there will be no foca.
Okay, thank you. Okay,
but like again, all right. Yeah. No,
we're going to react to just don't
worry. But like again, all right, notice
because they don't use the term doxing,
right? because they have condemned Kiwi
Farms. You no longer say Wi Masaki. Oh,
W Masaki. There you go. But like um
because because they no long because
they don't
>> Okay, let's
>> because they don't say doxing. What?
What do they say instead? What the [__]
do they say instead? They say what?
Wait, what did you say? Did you
>> Okay, where is the Queenman bed? Is
Queman just not mentioned here?
There is no mention of Queenman or Jtock
in this mod. Okay, cool. W
All I care about is that. I thought we
were getting to it, man.
I guess I want to see their reaction to
the Queenman clip that it's included
where he just like blatantly lies about
it.
don't leave their mom's basement, but
she sees the news. She saw two low-level
staffers at the Israeli embassy get shot
and killed. She's worried. So, I'm being
told by the police that I should go
online and see if this is really all I
care about. We're going to move on to
like Tommy after showing all of my
information and giving a hypothetical
where I'm a valid target because that's
>> I thought that video would have
something to do with Jay Stalker Queen.
I'm sorry, guys. I'm sorry. That's my
bad. That's my bad that I read the
title. That I read the title and then
the content of the video actually has
nothing to do with the title. That's my
bad.
>> He's a hypocrite.
>> Stevie said anything in Oh
no,
it's Queen.
>> Yeah.
I'm coming.
>> What is this face they're making?
>> I'm coming. involving this bad empanada
guy or anyone that supports him is
justifiable. Mo anything is justified
against bad empanada and any Why are we
saying this about bad empanada? Well, it
appears to me because bad empanada doxed
Willie Mac's wife. So would Destiny be
saying that those who dox people, those
who make calls to violence or illusions
to violence should be fair game and all
of their supporters, all the
personalities that back him up, all the
chatters that back him up.
>> This is essentially a Destiny snark
community. This guy's narrative for the
past 6 months is that I'm
>> and they just ignore it.
>> Covering for Destiny despite me making
two of the most in
>> Oh, that that's it. Oh, okay.
>> Depth videos criticizing him. Their
evidence behind this is I said Destiny
is better at covering the news than
Hassan and Vosch which is
>> again that's not what he said. What is
food jobs going to say? Yeah. Again,
again, I just want to say I just I just
want to say that
that the the only reason why they they
go after Willie Mack and they the only
reason why they don't defend Willie Mack
is just simply because Willie Mack is um
Willie Mack did do not condemn Destiny
enough. I don't care if you like
Destiny. I do not care if you like
Destiny. I care if you make like bad
videos where you lie in them, which is
what he did. Holy [__] Okay.
Yeah, this is just [__] Whatever.
So, they just ignore like the blatant
lie that Willie gave. Uh, and then they
go on to say like the only reason they
hate this guy is because he's not
completely condemning Destiny. Dude, I
like many people's content and promote
many people many people's content who do
not completely condemn Destiny. This is
just like a [__]
[__] [__] [__]
whatever. Only a two hour stream.
>> My thoughts keep telling me to get me
home. But my balls keep telling me to
let me. Oh, just let me. That clock
keeps like my balls keep telling me to
let me. Oh, just let me clocking like a
mesh from the telling me to get me home.
My balls keep telling me to let me [__]
all that shad
ass
the point drama cast.
>> No. So everybody's fighting and uh uh
was I was fighting till last month like
a month ago, two months ago and now I
have
>> now I'm not I don't have anything to do
with it. Dude, this guy has like a $500
mic and he doesn't know how to do audio.
It's so like this is so like genuinely
infuriating. This is so maddening to see
that he has like maybe plausibly like
thousands of dollars in audio equipment
and still his audio like sucks. I have
an excuse. I have like a $50 mic. Okay,
I have an excuse for my audio being bad.
This guy has no excuse. This is This is
horrific.
>> Change.
>> Jesus. Jesus. Jesus. Jesus.
So, I guess we're gonna go out over
Willy's video.
>> True, Brain Rod. True.
>> Um, but I I do think the video was, you
know, effective. And uh,
>> effective at what? I think the video was
effective.
>> The criticism I'm seeing out there,
>> don't undo it. I think a lot of people
are looking for that string that's like,
"Oh, you're hypocrites." And I don't
think that's going to wash. I don't
think it is washing.
>> Um,
>> unfortunately for me,
>> doesn't put me in the best spot.
>> Um, well, you got involved.
>> Now, oh, you did a stream on Willie. Was
it last weekend or the weekend before?
Weekend before. Um,
well, who'd have known? Will he Willy
Will he clap back? you know, I mean, I
guess
I I I hope that's not what was wanted. I
It's unfortunate,
seems kind of um
I don't know.
This guy just seems so [__]
uninterested. Okay, can we skip to when
he actually starts watching?
Let's skip to the to the Auggie bit, I
guess. I know I I I know pretty much
what he's going to say about Quean. We
can like watch it, I guess, but I I
think we can come to some conclusion
about what he's going to say about the
Queen and Bet.
>> Leave their mom's basement, but she sees
the news. She saw two low-level staffers
at the Israeli embassy get shot and
killed. She's worried. So, I'm being
told by the police that I should go
online and see if there's any direct
threats. And I see a video made by a guy
who hates me, showing all of my
information, and giving a hypothetical
where I'm a valid become real if he knew
they were giving out free wine.
>> Double No, actually, no. No, he likes if
they're giving out like dudes then he'd
be okay with it.
>> Destiny is a hypocrite.
>> Stevie said anything involving this bad
empanada guy or anyone that supports it.
>> See, this is this is this is
unbelievable because it's not that he's
running Willy's docks in the back. It's
already [__] public at this point.
>> Yeah. I need to boost the audio. Let's
Let's hear what he has to say about
that. Let's boost the audio. What does
What does he have to say here?
>> It's what he says. It's what he says is
ridiculous.
>> Like this. This is unbelievable.
>> It's unbelievable.
Ammo. Anything is justified against bad
empanada and anyone that supports him.
Let's apply those standards. Why are we
saying this about bad empanada? Well, it
appears to be because bad empanada doxed
Willie Mac's wife. So would Destiny be
saying that those who dox people, those
who make calls to violence or illusion?
>> I think it's fairly obvious that Queman
is dishonest,
call him out and he'll have an excuse
like it was a troll or a joke. This
what? All of these people are [__]
brained. Holy [__] Jesus Christ to viol
He can't even do it straight. You know
what he's doing.
>> Yeah, because it's a [__] hypocrisy.
It's funny. It's ridiculous. What are
you talking about?
>> Here, right? He's trying to show the
hypocrisy, but while he's [__]
spreading the docs more. Hey, I'm
spreading the docks of Destiny's tweet.
He is looking at Destiny's tweet. He is
looking at Destiny's tweet. Destiny
tweeted it. Destiny tweeted it. He is
looking at Destiny's tweet.
Holy [__] Okay, I'm not saying that.
Hey, how come you didn't show me the
same generosity uh that I that I showed
you? Why can't you show me the same
generosity? Now, Queven knows while this
is being played. Um there is a Willie
video. I have showed it to him and I was
the first one. Apparently, Queven's
first name shows up in a blink if you
miss it type situation and it's when he
was going over stuff. Um that's an
unacceptable error by Willie.
It's you can't do that. Got to be more
careful than that. But he I mean you
could see him with the [__] eating grin.
I mean I gota be honest this is comical
too.
>> Yeah you know but
>> okay like he understands it's a
hypocrisy. He just wants to like get a
dick at Kima. This is [__] [__]
Okay. Where where's the Auggie [__]
Let's look at his reaction to Auggie
[__] And that's all I really care
about. Let's see what he says about
Auggie
>> making authoritative statements then.
You know I mean look that that's a
pretty light criticism but Auggie does
that a lot. He's been doing it as long
as I know him, known him.
>> Confused. It's because he never plays
the original clip that made me mad in
the first place. He just summarizes as
they criticize Destiny and that's why
Willy's mad.
>> Too bothered by this, but instead he was
bothered by some stuff that um Queen and
J were saying. And basically what they
were saying was it's kind of
hypocritical for Destiny to get upset
at, you know, Willie Mack for getting
doxed when he has a history of doxing
people and is currently right now
calling for their doxes. Right.
>> So he never plays the context and then
acts like the reason I'm mad is because
they called Destiny a hypocrite. Nothing
about my wedding or my bride. How is
that possible unless
>> Yeah. Th this is where I want all you to
explain himself. I I I want to
understand this,
>> right? I I have no idea what's going on.
Like
his wedding was I mean, look, I'll be
the first to say he didn't handle it
right. He shouldn't shouldn't have uh he
poked a bear in in in some in some way
in some ways, but it it's pretty
important. You know, he's replying to
these tweets and he's getting into with
these guys and he's got days towards his
wedding and Auggie Auggie's been there
before.
>> You're being bad faith. I'm not even
sure if Auggie knows what a dog whistle
is. He's like, "Unless Queman pulls up
Willy's docs and then says, "I love
doxing Willie, it's all fine."
>> Really a point against Willie Mac. It
was mainly a point against Destiny. I
don't think at any point Queen was like,
>> "Yeah, and he got doxed and I love
that."
>> Yeah, but you don't really have to say
that, Auggie.
>> Where? Why would Queen be okay with
Willie being doxed? Where have you Okay,
this is [__] This is [__] I
mean, I don't really know what I
expected. Sure. This is [__] I
don't I don't know what I expected. Uh
is he still live?
>> It's a B.
>> Yes,
>> he is still live. All right, I'm
probably just going to raid out into him
if I can. I don't know if he has it on.
Uh we've been live for only two hours.
I'm going to go work on the video. I'm
going to be honest. I'm going to go work
on the video. I'm going to go look at uh
work on the video. Do more research.
Write write some [__] Okay. We we be
writing and [__]
Uh
hold on.
Okay. Do I need to like Hold on. Let me
see if I can I don't even know if I love
you. Kisses. Thank you. Thank you.
Smile.
There's like not much more I can I can
do. And I I I do want to start, you
know, I am subscri Okay, hold. Let me
see if I can Does he even have it on?
Yeah, he does. All right, I'm just going
to raid into him. I'm probably going to
watch this off stream as well uh when I
go off. I just don't want to [__] rip
the content. I'm going to go work on the
video. I want to get this video out. Uh
the sooner the better. I think uh I have
worthwhile criticisms that I should that
should be made into a video. I think
people are like too scared to talk about
this. Um or like too scared to because
it involves doxing. Not not everyone,
but I think a lot of people are too
scared to talk about this. Um, and I I
want a video out there to uh to show how
[__] stupid and dishonest Willie is.
I think that's important. All right.
Bye, guys. Love you. Smile. Smile. Heart
emoji. Smile. Heart emoji. Bye.
>> Oh, hey. What's up, bro? How's it going,
>> dude? It is like I don't know. I I I
don't know if I'm like naive and this
has just happened all the time and I'm
only realizing it now that I'm like
paying attention, but this is crazy.
Like every single clip, maybe being a
little hyperbolic, but like most of the
clips in the video are either cut short,
cut context,
>> disingenuous, or just like outright
lies. Like the clip when he talks about
Queman, he's like Quimman's saying this
is justified against me. He's talking
about Destiny.
>> What the like
>> he is literally saying under Destiny's
worldview, which is insane and I don't
share. This is what is allowed. Yes,
obviously. He's he's he's obviously
making a reference to Destiny because in
the month of July alone he like did a
whole like an insane amount of doxing
stuff. Like it's like obviously he's
referencing Destiny and then he's like
um I don't know what should happen to
Destiny but bad empanada should be
banned. And it's like these people do
the same thing. You should be
consistent. Yeah. If you want bad
empanada banned, Destiny should be
banned too. There's no way that when
when uh Noah just when Noah restates
information from a known liar who doxes
people who is like a horrible
reputation, right? And Willie goes, "He
said this without evidence. It's so
disgusting that they do this when his
entire like 15-minute section here is
just him doing the exact same thing Noah
was doing, right? It's just him
repeating Destiny's garbage instead of
Noah repeating bad and Panata's garbage.
And he just doesn't connect it
whatsoever. You literally can't connect
it at all.
>> Yeah. I I Dude, it's like I I I had like
the first part of my script written for
uh for the Willy Mac thing. I have to
like go through and rewrite everything
because I was just going to call him
like like Yeah, he was probably
emotional, but like this is not how you
respond to like your docs getting out.
But at this point, he's just like
completely and utterly malicious. He's
like using his wife. I saw Aiden tweet
this and I like agree. He's literally
using his wife as like a human shield.
He's like, "Dude, my wife was scared she
was going to get shot in the head. My
wife is like like, "Bro, what? You you
did this. You confirmed the docs 3 days
before your wedding, right? It sucks
that you got bomb threats or whatever,
if that's even true." But like, you
confirmed this. You you allowed this
avenue of attack. You went on your
Twitter, said, "This is real. This is
where my wife and I are going to be in 3
days." Like, it it's it's so insane how
he can just
>> Cherry asked him to take down that
audio. Right. Cherry asked him to take
down that audio and his response was, "I
don't think this really hurts you in any
way." Uh, so no, I should go to YouTube
legal.
>> Yeah. No, he's he's he's crazy. I I I
don't I don't get it. I I I genuinely
don't get it. I don't understand it. And
then he's like he's going after um and
like he's so inconsistent in the video.
He's like, I don't care that like uh or
Destiny was I don't care that Destiny
was defending me. My docs is already
viral. And then he's complaining that
like um he's like, well Auggie showed my
docs uncensored. And it's like, bro, do
you care? Do you not care? Like his
arguments change every five seconds.
>> Did Auggie show his docs uncensored?
>> Yeah, that was one of his arguments.
>> Oh, no, no, no. He showed he showed
links to my docs uncensored.
>> Uh, I believe his as well when he was
covering uh him. Sure. I mean, yeah,
yours as well.
>> I thought No, no, no. I thought he
actually argued he was actually upset
that they didn't play the Queen clip,
right? I thought that was what it was.
They were He was upset that they didn't
play the Queen clip or Sorry, Audi
didn't play the Queen. I
>> I could be mixing things up. There was a
lot in the video. Um,
>> yeah, I'll show the dipper suite. But,
uh, one of Willy's criticisms is also,
so if it's he didn't show my doc or he
showed my docs,
>> what do you guys think of Loerbox's take
on doxing? Uh, is this actually real?
I'll pull it up. He He's mad that Auggie
didn't watch the clip with Queen in it,
right? He is. He's actually mad about
that yellow. Well, I guess
>> here. Hold on.
>> And the the light shines back.
>> Does Dan Saltman know the identity of
that yellow cat grifter? Well, I guess
everyone does now because it's
published. Yeah. And I just I'm sorry. I
can't have any sympathy for someone who
does it to other people. Like why would
you? I think if you dox people, you you
deserve to get docked. So I'm go geez.
Uh so then it starts to become okay.
Then is this not just the um it's so up
in a world where they're also just lying
about what other people do or what
they're involved in? Like I'd say you
have to like actually maliciously dox
people yourself. That has to be the
standard, right? You have to say I'm
publishing this information because I
hate this person or something. or even
for any reason you're just publishing
the information yourself because I I
that sounds like that could be a
position I don't care about or would be
but I you'd have to know right they'd
have to do it themselves it can't just
be based on innuendo that can't be it
can't be the line
>> if a doer gets doxed or something like
that it's like I I will never feel bad
for that
>> like I wouldn't feel bad for bad and
panic plays by those rules I wouldn't
feel bad for Destiny plays by those
rules right anybody plays by those but
it's it sucks when you're somebody who
doesn't and explicitly says they don't
and explicitly like disavows it and then
people like you play by those rules,
huh? Nobody cares if you get doxed,
right? That's is
>> in that case.
>> That's I don't know. It's [__] crazy.
>> I can't believe he he straight up just
says, "Well, Queen's community doxes
people with no evidence. Lays out zero
evidence for that point." His his
evidence for like wants me doxed is
Queman laughed when he said when he
disavowed the comment.
>> I don't know if you want to pull it up.
I did DM you while you were at that
section, but like yeah, his his whole
thing with like Queenman's community
docs me. It's just a total lie if you
look into it for like five seconds. It's
just totally false. Like he just lies. I
don't even know if he looked into it. I
don't even know if I can call it like a
malicious lie. It could just be a
mistake. I don't know. But like it's
just wrong. It's just wrong. You can
look at where he said I don't know if
I'm allowed to say the word on the
stream, so I'll be vague. But you can
look at where he says the docs
originated. Look who posted
>> Kiwi Farms. I don't care if you say Kiwi
Farms on here. I mean, it seems like
Yeah,
>> it's just like the guy who posted no
mention of so nothing
>> two posts two posts on his account. None
of them mention Queman. It It's
ridiculous. It's like
>> I think it just has to be Malice at this
point. I mean Malice is clouding his
judgment, but his judgment is so
compromised. Like Malice can cloud
anybody's judgment, right? But most
people are like out of self-preservation
are like, "Yeah, I hate this person, but
I'm not going to go shoot them in the
head in the head. Not because I want
them to be happy or healthy, but because
I don't want to go to jail, right? Or
not even necessarily because of my own
morality. Uh I would say for me, my
morality, I don't want to kill people.
But I'm just saying hypothetically, you
could do it out of self-preservation,
too. Most people, even if they don't
have a moral like qual with something,
if it's like really bad, they won't do
it. But that's just not kicking in for
Willie. He's just like lying. And he's
like, I feel like this should risk his
channel, right? Like in terms of his his
viewership. Like he is just
transparently lying. There should just
be easy videos that go up about this and
show how he's transparently lying. Who c
I think it's crazy if Nicholas doesn't
react to this video cuz he very often
does react to Willie Mack videos and if
he doesn't say like I need to see some
evidence of this, you can't just say
this with no evidence, right? Because I
think the evidence is Queman called
somebody, right? I think the evidence is
basically Queman was mad at Hutch.
Queenman thinks Hutch is a and then
Hutch's docs were posted in that thread
or was posted in that thread and that is
a progression that happened through
time. You cannot blame that on Quimman
one because the docs was already posted
in the thread before that. Hutch's docs
was posted in the thread before Queman
ever talked about him. Okay, before Que
ever had his little thing with Hutch,
Hutch's docs was in that thread. So one,
it's not even the original like it
wasn't the original source of the docs
where that came out. Okay, and two,
Quimman doesn't like that. He doesn't
direct people to do that. And even if
Destiny's Kiwi Farms thread watches
Queman because they think he's funny,
you cannot blame Quman for giving his
thoughts and then them going, "Well, I
guess uh this person." Yeah, Queen made
some really good points about how much
of a that is or how much of a that guy
is. I'm going to go after him. Yeah, we
disavow that. Do not do that. I guess
the other you and Queen are literally
the only like community adjacent to
Destiny, I feel. maybe loner box too I I
or whatever but like who openly say like
don't dox this is bad this is wrong do
not do this destiny literally encourages
it like I I don't know and how how does
Willie come to these conclusions where
it's like queen and and Jay doc's
community are doing this it's Destiny it
is literally Destiny that's doing this
everybody that is doxed in this space
you can tie it back to Destiny it's like
it's so
>> dude and the funny thing is is I don't
want to reference like specific things
there's like a lot of evidence of this
that Destiny is malicious with this. The
Destiny will direct people to Kiwi Farms
to dox them explicitly. Right. There's a
lot of evidence. I literally wrote that
in my script.
>> Sorry. You can you can put Anna on
there. There's new evidence. There's
like new things that happened. I I But I
don't want to go through it, right? Like
obviously like this guy is just totally
malicious.
>> But I'm saying Anna because it's like
years old. I think that's safe to bring
up.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Well, she
literally called him out for it, right?
>> Yeah. Yeah. So I there there is evidence
of him implicitly and explicitly and
Yeah. am sorry. Go ahead. I I didn't
mean to interrupt that.
>> Oh, I was just going to say anonymous,
thank you for the gifted sub. You can go
off explicitly. Implicitly.
>> Yeah, he there there is like numerous
evidence of him implicitly and
explicitly uh doing doces, supporting
doces, sending people to doc
information. Like I I it this video like
I I know it's like mostly mostly or if
not mostly like in part a meme that that
Willie still likes Destiny, right? But
with this video, he he has to purposely
ignore so much to get to the conclusions
that he does. It's like, I don't think
Destiny should be banned, but bad and
panata. It's like, bro, Destiny has done
this for longer. He's done it to greater
severity. Uh Bad and Panata, as far as I
understand, correct me if I'm wrong,
obviously. Has he hasn't he only doxed
creators?
>> Um I don't know.
>> Okay. Well, I don't want to speak on
that then if you don't know. Um yeah,
>> I literally don't know the same. don't
feel any need to
>> I they're the same. I don't feel any
need to like really defend or or like
even classify what bad empata does cuz
it it's like literally all that does is
give people the ability to go well
actually there's this thing bad empanad
did that's way worse so you're wrong.
It's like okay I don't have to I don't
have to even reference bad empanada like
bad empanada I don't I don't care I just
reference this
>> I said this on my stream but literally
the only difference between bad empanada
and destiny is one of them is like being
accused of multiple crimes. It's like
both of these people are bad. One of
them is like significantly worse. I feel
like I I I don't know. Like how can you
make this video? Destiny is the one who
signal He also says like Bad Empanada is
the one who who signal boosted it and
made it go viral. Destiny's Twitter post
had 200,000 views. Bad Empanad's video
to this day only has 70,000. I don't
understand how you could think that Bad
Empanada is the one that made this go
viral.
>> Like the Gat Fumodor post, you'd have to
you'd have to subtract all the views
from Destiny's quote tweet, right? Like
I don't even know if Gadof Fumor's post.
I don't know how wide that would have
gone,
>> but um like Destiny was probably the
person amplifying it most and Destiny's
a lightning rod. Like when Destiny does
quote tweet something that is going to
get push back from people that is going
to amplify it massively. Like the ampl
amplification factor of like Destiny's
tweets versus most people's like he will
get way more engagement with his tweets.
Yeah, exactly. Alien mode. Yeah, I just
think I think when you go like Well,
actually Destiny's probably worse. It's
just like Yeah, maybe. But I don't
really care. They're both Yeah. pieces
of [__]
Really? I just to be clear, I'm not
trying to like tier list this like
Destiny is actually just like the
specific line in his video where it's
like one of these people should be
banned and one of them shouldn't. It's
like okay, no, like be consistent,
please. You I don't I don't you don't
need I you don't need to tier list. You
don't need to say like one of them's
worse, one of them is whatever. Both of
them spread doces. Uh both of them do
bad things. If you want to have a
position that doxing is bad and you
should be banned off of a platform if
you spread doces, uh then you should
have the position that Destiny should
also be banned. Don't do this. [__]
where you're still trying to appeal to
DGG and say like no actually Destiny
shouldn't be banned. It's like it it's
so it's so it's so stupid. Like both of
them or none of them. You can't have it
[__] both ways. I don't know.
>> Uh I do like that he also was like I
don't even know how this guy stole a
platform. It's like dude if you if I'll
forgive Willie for everything. Okay,
I'll forgive him for everything he's
ever done to me. Okay, for against me
I'll forgive it all. I'll love Willie if
he gets like if he convinces somehow
somebody at YouTube to start looking at
off-platform behavior and evaluating
that under the YouTube toos to like ban
people for extreme offplatform behavior.
Let's go. That's all I need. That's all
I need. That'd be awesome. Cuz holy
[__] there are some people who need
some YouTube justice for for their
actions. Okay, apparently Nicholas is
going to watch the video tomorrow. We'll
see what he has to say.
>> Oh, I saw food shops is watching it
today. I I went live and then like 20
minutes later they went live. I should
have stayed cuz I wanted to see what
they had to say. I watched them over the
um the Brad Tay stuff. They watched
Destiny's stuff and they were saying
some like really [__] So I want to I
want to watch that tomorrow as well.
>> That's the Yeah, that's the new DG brain
trust over there. The the server
>> they were they were begging for it,
dude. They were begging for it. Brad
Tate's girlfriend was begging to be hit.
Okay. She deserved it. She deserved to
get mouth punched. All right. With his
like meth face.
>> It's crazy stuff. It's wild and crazy
stuff. Uh guys, I just going to do a
show real quick. Guys, if you like the
content, please consider subscribing,
donating. Okay. Explanation boy. Donate
in the chat. We'll give you the TTS
methods. We're I don't know. We're some
amount of money before for more away
from more hours on the stream. I'll do
discussions. If we aren't getting much
for donos, I'm probably going to head
out after I do some discussions on this
and maybe look at some some of the
Twitter comments. You guys got Twitter
links. Okay. Hey, if you see Twitter
commentary, funny tweets about this [__]
my way. Let me let me see it all cuz
I've not got I didn't get a chance to go
look around on Twitter before this. So,
there's funny stuff my way. All right.
Anyway, um yeah,
>> what else needs to be said? It's also
kind of that I feel like it would be
cool to go and do like Twitter spaces or
have a conversation around this like
make it sort of more interesting, but
>> everybody's too scared to stand up
against Willie. It's like
>> no at this point. I would say all the
people who are willing to actually take
a look at this and call it out also
have already done so like like really is
Willie behaving is Willie exhibiting any
new behavior here? I feel like
everything he's done here he's already
been criticized for. This is just more
egregious and embarrassing of an
example. But like he's he already was
just replatforming Destiny.
>> That's [__] that's ballsy.
>> I guess he he went he went at Auggie.
He's going to get he's going to get his
cheeks clapped for that. I do think it's
really funny that Oh, hold on. Wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. Oh,
there's no way he'll hop on. I'm gonna
message Auggie. We'll see if he's gonna
come on.
>> I did want to ask him because there was
um
uh Willie says that like Auggie I had a
conversation with Auggie and Auggie said
the reason he quit is because he was
being doxed and if that wasn't private
and he just confirmed that Auggie was
getting doxed and potentially confirmed
>> it was it was definitely public. It was
definitely public that they were like
trying to find him that like Salvo was
trying to find.
>> I don't know if it was public that
that's the reason Auggie quit. I think
most people just thought that like oh he
just got bored did something else and
then came back later.
>> Yeah. But I'm saying it's like already
public they were trying to dox him and I
think like I think the city he lived in
was public at the time too or something.
I think
>> so I'm saying I don't I don't think
there is more there. I don't know. Maybe
maybe you could argue that like you're
kind of giving away that that irritated
Auggie and like you're sort of giving an
attack surface and that's not
appreciated, right? Like oh this really
really bugged him when uh somebody's
trying to dox him. Like it just seems
like something to say that like if he
ever gets in a fight with somebody,
you're maybe giving
>> let's say let's say you get doxed and
then you quit and but you don't tell
anybody. Nobody knows that you got doxed
and you quit because you got doxed like
full address. Everything's out there,
right? And then like a year later you
come back and then you only tell one
person and that one person's like, "Oh
yeah, he quit because he got doxed." I
feel like that in like all that
information, right? When when
>> Oh, you're good.
>> Oh, go ahead.
>> You roboted for a second.
>> You're good.
>> Oh, my bad. I I feel like it that
inadvertently confirms the the the docs,
right? Whereas if if the person does not
confirm it, it's it's more or less like
left up in the air, like plausible
deniability, stuff like that, right?
Does that make sense what I'm getting
at?
>> Sure. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah, I don't I don't
believe any of that is a concern here
necessarily, but I guess we'll see as
stuff comes out.
>> Yeah, I mean I I would want to ask him
to clarify. Um obviously I don't I don't
I'm not I'm not friends with a guy. I
don't have it in contact, so I I
wouldn't know. But yeah, if he comes on,
I'd like to ask him about that cuz
that's crazy. That's crazy. If he's if
he's doing like I don't know. I I
>> This is like the This is such a bad
video, dude. Holy [__]
>> Um Yeah, it's goofy. I don't know. I I
take call-ins, but like nobody ever
wants to call in. Um
I don't I just don't get DJers anymore.
I don't know. I It sucks, but it's like
obvious cuz like I know people call in,
but we need uh we need different topics.
The DJers have been humiliated too many
times. They've lost all will to live in
this server. Very sad.
>> Very, very sad.
>> How would you describe your community?
cuz I feel like you and Queman's
community, maybe not Queman so much, but
like your community at least is very
very like DG and Jason, right?
>> Um, yeah, there's like overlap or there
used to be a lot of overlap. I don't
know if there's as much overlap anymore.
>> I just feel like when he when he says
like JTO has a DXing community, it's
like that's not too far off from
Destiny. Like I don't know if like that
you you cover a lot of Destiny, you talk
about Destiny, you're in the same like
broad sphere as him. Like these are not
two separate communities of people that
never interact with each other, are
never the same people. It's like come
on. I I like I don't know. It's just
like when you say Jtock has a docs and
community, not so much Queen because I
think I think Quimman kind of has his
own thing. But like with you
specifically, it's like no, you really
don't. It's like a lot of if people in
your community dock, it's like they're
more
>> Destiny participated in this community
for a long time. So I don't know if he
says like, "Oh, all these people
joined." But then even if they join,
it's like they take screenshots of my
server. Is that like being a part of a
If taking screenshots of my server is
going to make you like a Kiwi farmer or
something, then I got bad news for
Destiny with his 20 albums of plugs from
from my server. So,
>> yeah.
>> Uh there's a lot of XD in the Discord.
True. There are. That's facts. And I
don't know if you uh if you guys do want
to call in, you join the callins
channel. If you got any points that we
haven't brought up on stream yet, you
join the channel. I'm just looking for I
don't know more um more of this more
tweets around this. Let me go. Let me go
look into this. See what's going on. No,
not that. No, not that. No, not that.
See here. Oh, I don't have music playing
either. Damn. Let me pull up music here
real quick, guys. Oh, the cabal is angry
with me. And I'm not going to specify
which one. Did anything else get said
here? It's both.
I'm not specifying which one. It's both.
That's funny. Uh, I don't think
>> I'm going to head off. I'll watch. If if
something epic happens, I'll be
watching. Okay. If something epic
happens, I'll be watching. into
>> talk.